This is Jocko podcast number 36 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Okay,
good evening echo.
Good evening.
Behold
the world is a sight to behold.
I'm just back from a trip to the wilderness in the Sierra mountains of
California.
And every time you open your eyes there's a sight to behold,
an image of beauty
from a distance,
a mountain of solid granted almost a hundred million years old,
juts up from the valley floor
up close the roots of a newborn tree trying to find purchase maneuvering around
and over and through rock until it finds soil.
Yeah.
And in doing so draws an infinitely complex picture of life.
Yes,
the world is a beautiful place,
but we also know
that the world can be a horrible place for wretched place.
And in the military I was usually sent to the bad places
and in a way I was sent to those bad places to deal with them.
Okay.
To keep them away from us.
Those of us lucky enough to be born in the right country with the right form of
government and the right supply of water and food and energy.
And it was our job
as the lucky ones.
Okay.
To keep the horror away,
to shield the eyes of the blessed,
but there are other people
whose job it is to open eyes,
to show the world,
not just the light,
okay,
but also the darkness
and that's the life of a photographer
and like the soldier,
he must travel and like the soldier,
he must take risk then like the soldier,
he must face the darkness and live with it
and like the to an even greater degree,
he must detach from what is happening.
He must observe from the outside be a part of what is happening in front of him
without being a part of what is happening in front of him.
We have a guest on the podcast tonight,
friend of mine who spent his life with a camera in his hand capturing light
and capturing darkness.
Welcome to the podcast Mr Kiran Daugherty,
who in addition to being a friend,
an outstanding drummer,
a husband,
a dad,
and last but not least,
an award winning photographer.
Welcome to the pod pat podcast.
Karen,
thank you for having me.
Good to have you on detected a little accent there.
You're from,
uh,
it's an English accent.
You entertains.
Yeah.
Just a little on that.
So you're from England and how did this whole business start?
How did you end up start taking pictures?
How did I start taking pictures?
Um,
my dad was a good photographer,
always had a camera and I think I got to my 17th birthday and he gave his
cameras to my sister.
Now I had no interest in the cameras at the time,
but I suddenly had an interest when I found he gave them to my sister.
So I demanded that I have them.
I had to do some sort of swap,
but I got the cameras.
Um,
but I didn't really use them.
I really wanted to be an artist.
I wanted to paint,
but I wasn't good enough in my own eyes.
I was okay,
but not good enough.
So the camera became a tool for me to create and express myself.
And
I ended up,
I did a degree course after school in sports science and then I went on to do,
oops.
Yeah.
Hey listen.
It was a great course.
I had three years playing tennis and football.
I mean,
come on.
Who's a great games?
So,
um,
I wasn't,
I,
I wasn't really good enough to get onto an art foundation course.
So I did the sports course and then I wanted to concentrate on doing a course in
photography.
So my mum found a course for me and there's only one causing the country.
And then he took 12 people and normally had to apply five or six times to get
on.
And so when I applied for the course,
I went for an interview and I showed a portfolio of appalling black and white
pictures that I shot.
I mean,
really appalling.
I'd gone to a couple music festivals and
I had pictures of dribbling babies in prams.
I mean,
this is what I took to my interview,
but they put me on the reserve list.
So I was number 13 and it meant that I wasn't going to get on the course cause
they were only taking two earth.
So my mom every day for about six months,
rang the head tooth and said,
come on,
put them on the course and come on,
put them on the course.
And after six months,
he just thought to stop this woman calling me every day.
Okay.
And he put me on his number 13 on the course and I did the course.
Um,
and I ended up spending most of my weekends traveling at home down to an agency
at home where I,
you were really working.
So the course was teaching you how to do stuff and,
but the job that I wanted to do,
you can't learn it in a classroom really.
It's a bit of common sense and just reacting to the environment around you.
So I used to spend my weekends traveling home and working for a real agency and
they would just send me out on stuff and I would be shooting pictures,
developing transparencies,
black and whites printing,
putting it on why a drum,
sending it into the papers,
you know,
in the real one.
That's what do my weekends.
And then I go back to the course and I just felt the course was really dragging
for me.
Um,
but I finished it.
And the root is you join a regional newspaper and then you sort of cut your
teeth in the industry.
Then you go to maybe a big provincial paper and then you head down to maybe
London for work on a national and then maybe after the national you might
consider working on agency.
Well,
I didn't have time for any of that,
so I just went straight down to the London out of college.
Um,
and tried to
try,
I tried to get a job,
but I ended up,
what you end up doing is you go around and you just spec pictures into
newspapers.
So you find a job,
you shoot it,
you ring them up and you say,
I have this great picture and you need to,
you really should have it.
And they would say,
okay,
bring it in.
And you would take it in.
And they go,
thanks.
But we had our own photographer there and blah,
blah.
So I did this for two or three years,
not really getting anywhere.
And uh,
I ended up,
I learned a few tricks of the trade,
which is you turn up to a news event that's happening and you shoot the pictures
and then you ring the desk,
the wire desk,
wherever it is,
you want to sell the picture too.
And you say,
listen,
very few people were here and this is a big story and really you can't afford
not to take this from me because your opposition was here.
Um,
and I think you really should see this picture.
So they'd say,
come in.
And I went in once and I'd shot this picture of this tank that appeared outside
the High Court in London.
And coming out of this tank was a 20 foot Marlin.
It was just the most ridiculous thing.
And it was some guy protesting about a divorce.
He was going through Siri just loaded up the t just headed out the court slugged
yet.
Yup.
And I drove,
I was driving past a with a friend and I thought,
I better shoot that picture.
And I shot that picture and I rang up and I said,
listen,
Associated Press,
we're here Reuters,
you really should take this picture of me.
And I went in and it was such a ridiculous looking image that they said,
great,
we'll take it.
And so they just snip the negatives because it was filming those days they take
three negatives,
the one in the middle,
they want a Biz,
the one they scan,
um,
and that was 75 pounds in my pocket.
And I just thought,
right,
I need to keep doing this.
I said,
if I come in here with a picture,
is it,
do you give me 75 pounds?
Every time I come in?
They said,
well,
every picture we take,
we'll pay you 75 pounds.
So of course I just can't ring him.
And kept ringing them and kept bringing them and eventually they cottoned onto
the amount of 75 pounds.
They were giving me an a day and they said,
okay,
listen,
we'll put you on shift so we will pay you a hundred pounds and you will work
five shifts.
We will stop paying you five times 75 every time you come in.
And that's how it started.
And um,
so it's a bit of luck and a bit of determination.
Um,
and yeah,
that's how,
that's how I got into it.
And if I'm totally honest,
I really didn't know that that sort of job existed.
Um,
I'd seen magazines by photographers and like Don McCullen who used to shoot the
troubles in Northern Ireland in the early days.
And he used to see his spreads on the Sunday Times,
but it never dawned on,
I used to look at the images was mesmerized by these black and white images,
but never put two and two together and worked at,
well,
sorry.
So this is obviously a job and somebody does this and he's paid to do this.
Um,
and so yeah,
it sort of dawned on me,
there's this,
this is an existence that I really quite liked because I don't have to wear a
suit.
I can wear jeans and a tee shirt and I can just shoot and create and I can earn
a living.
And that's really how it started.
And then you ended up staying at Reuters for what,
10 years?
Uh,
no,
from 1993 to 2008,
so I was freelance until 2000 and then 2000,
um,
when,
which was really fortunate as cause my first daughter was born,
they made me staff.
So there was the security of the job there.
Um,
and then I resigned in 2008 so I'd sort of done my stint of staff and I decided
that I wanted to move on to other things.
Um,
but yeah,
it was a bumpy road,
but it was an,
I couldn't have asked for a better grounding into photojournalism than working
for a wire agency in that Reuters because you just got to cover everything from
spot news from something that was happening in Downing Street to
covering Wimbledon to covering world cups.
Olympic Games was owns,
um,
you name it,
there was nothing a wire agency photographer didn't cover.
And so,
you know,
you literally,
you could,
you could come off from shooting a Champions League football match and the next
day you could be in Afghanistan shooting,
shooting a new story.
That's,
that's how it worked.
And that's incredibly intoxicating,
especially when you're a young guy,
you know,
I mean,
I didn't get to travel immediately.
Obviously I had to cut my teeth and they had to trust that they could send me
away.
And I must admit it took,
took a couple of couple of years.
Um,
and in fact,
my first assignment by my line manager,
he just said to me,
one Friday night,
I need to go to Belfast,
the third for July the 12th for the troubles.
And I said,
I can't.
And he said,
what do you mean?
I said,
well,
I,
I'm,
I've got a gig tonight.
I'm playing in London and there were 13 other people in the band and if I get on
a plane,
they're not going to have a drama.
Wrong answer.
So,
so you went to Belfast?
Nope.
Oh,
you didn't do the health,
the Gig,
the Gig Bros for,
because I didn't realize I was too naive to realize the implications of y y you
know,
sorry,
this guy wants to work for Reuters and I'm going to send them to Belfast to
cover that.
The troubles.
And he wants to play drums in a club.
Yeah.
So I learned that lesson pretty quick.
How long did it take to get another offer to travel like that?
Um,
I think the Belfast offer was 95 and then I ended up traveling literally 98.
So it's pretty on the bench for three years.
I mean,
yeah,
totally.
But when I did get to go,
he waited till I been married a month and then said to me,
I need you to go away for four months.
I'm just just married.
I've been married for a month and you want me to go in here?
And it was the Caribbean,
believe it or not to photograph cricket England against the West indies.
So it wasn't that tough gig.
And I ended up being able to take my wife with me as well.
So,
um,
so you can't complain about that at all?
Not at all at all.
We had a great time.
So tell me about like a little bit about the times where you went to Belfast and
what that was like for the first time we are going.
Okay.
Do you feel that tension for the first time you feel kind of the presence of
violence around you?
I was a nervous wreck and bearing in mind that I had lived in Belfast,
so,
um,
I lived in there during that at the side of the troubles and uh,
fulfill your five or six years of my life.
I was there,
although I never experienced any of the troubles.
It was very protected from it.
But um,
yeah,
I mean,
you know,
I went back and I was petrified.
I thought,
where do I go?
What,
what,
where,
where can I not go?
And I was very conscious of my name,
very Catholic name.
And there are certain areas of growth.
For those of you who don't know Karen's name is,
is the same name as one of the,
the heroes of the Ira Ira and who actually died in prison from a,
from a hunger strikes event.
That's your name.
So there's no,
that's my name.
There's no hiding that one.
Absolutely.
And of course,
just to clarify,
was not named after him butts,
just coincidence.
But there are murals.
We'll have a Belfast with Kiron Duck.
So there were certain areas of Belfast I could walk into very easily.
Um,
and there were certain areas of Belfast that I didn't really want to be caught
with my Prescott in my pocket.
So,
um,
so yeah,
it was,
yeah,
I was,
I was petrified.
You know,
there's no snow Arthur White stripe it in.
Did you start thinking yourself,
well,
maybe this isn't the job for me,
or did you,
were you thinking yourself?
I'm scared,
but this is awesome.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Of what I figured.
Yeah.
Cause yeah,
that's,
that's sort of the typical,
you know,
when I talked to obviously all,
all my friends in the military,
that's everyone's feeling,
you know,
hey,
I was scared,
but that was awesome.
Yeah.
That's what everybody wants to do.
And I mean,
as a photographer,
when you're in there and there's the potential to have those shots,
those moments,
um,
of,
of human existence,
that only happened at that place at that time.
And you've got that opportunity that,
yeah,
I mean,
you'll waiting,
the worst thing is you get over that and there's nothing happening because
that's what happens.
Know,
leading up to July the 12th and the,
maybe the pockets of violence and that that happened usually in the evenings
after the pubs closed.
Um,
imagine that,
you know,
I mean,
yeah,
I know.
And the one thing he did,
it made the flames really stand out when they did throw this petro bums,
you know,
but what you were doing was you,
you'd be doing a lot of driving around and there would be nothing and you'd get
back to your hotel.
Anything,
okay,
what am I going to file today?
You know,
I'm over here,
I'm being paid to be here and I need to be filing some imagery just to sort of
justify the air flight out here and what not.
So [inaudible] and it would be really tough.
And so those were the toughest moments because you are having to find images
that sort of told the story,
but they weren't really the reason why you were there.
He was sending them because they were expecting trouble and then he'd be sitting
in the bar at night and somebody would say,
right,
this is happening on the falls road.
And you'd go,
great.
And we just go straight out there.
And if you had something physical happening in front of you,
it's almost as if he needed to get one under your belt to calm down because then
you were able to say,
okay,
I've produced something from here that's noteworthy and newsworthy.
Um,
and sometimes you go on these trips and to be nothing for a week and you'd be
sitting in your head in the,
behind the scene in the hotel and there'd be nothing for a week.
And that,
that was the worst.
But as soon as something did happen,
it was then a catalyst for maybe something else to happen.
And if there was something happening that night,
there was always the clear up the next morning.
So that was then the catalyst for actually what would maybe happen during the
week.
Um,
and one thing would lead to another and you'd end up beginning to feel a little
bit more confident.
And,
you know,
I was just watching the guys that were a lot older than me and far more
experienced and I just sort of hung around with those guys,
sort of,
you're just trying to work out what do you do?
And that's how you learn.
You just watch how these other photographers are doing it and you just think,
okay,
well I'll remember that next time.
And because these guys come in and they just look to mentally cool and you know,
they sort of knew what they were doing.
And also to just,
did you ever,
ever a time period where you thought you were more bad ass than your war or were
you always pretty humble about,
hey,
you know what,
these guys,
they,
they know more than me.
I'm just going to watch him and learn.
Um,
I mean you obviously thought you were pretty bad ass when you're like,
you know what,
I'm not going for the regional vapor.
I'm going straight to London.
Yeah.
Job.
Yeah,
you're right.
But honestly,
I don't know where that came from.
I just thought I'd lost enough time.
I think I kind of hang around doing,
you know,
I mean no district and there were no jobs going anyway at the end of the
coolest.
So I just thought,
well you know,
so yeah,
bad ass and probably not.
Um,
I mean I'm still,
if I'm,
I,
I'm not really wanting to work with other photographers now,
but when you're working in fleet street and you're working for a news agency,
you can't help but be in the pack and you're always working with other
photographers.
And there are,
as time goes by the,
there are sort of few photographers that you begin to sort of look to.
You can sort of work out which of the ones that are doing something similar to
the way you want to be doing it.
And there are others that do their own thing cause it all photographers are
completely different that you're gonna have 10 photographers standing next to
each other and they can all shoot the same picture.
But every single image will be completely different because each photographer
has decided there's a different part of what's happening in front of him that he
wants to concentrate on.
So,
and that's what I found,
you know,
was happening a lot with,
especially with your sent down to Downing Street to do the prime minister and
the prime minister,
it would just walk,
the door would open and the premise will walk out of the door and get into the
car and drive off you take and it was seven pictures.
Yeah.
And the guy next to you could be a,
could be at uh,
uh,
a trainee and he will stand there and he'll shoot the same imagery with the same
cameras in the same lens and that you wouldn't be able to tell the difference
between a guy who's been doing it 20 years and a trainee because that's a very
sort of orchestrated theatrical moment,
you know?
And that's,
I didn't,
I wasn't really interested in that sort of stuff.
I was interested in stuff that was really spontaneous,
sporadic.
And it happened and you had to be ready for it and you had to react to it.
And that's what I like to do,
react
to what was happening.
Did.
Did you feel like going to Ireland in the,
in the late nineties and early 2000 did you feel that that prepared you at all
for,
for going to Iraq for going to the other places that he went to in the world?
Was it good up her preparatory step?
Yeah,
absolutely.
And you know,
to be totally honest,
I've never even thought about that.
That thought has never crossed my mind until you just said it.
Did you think that prepared man actually,
do you know?
Yeah,
of course it did.
But it's funny when you were working you don't,
you don't think about things like that.
You don't,
I mean if I'd kept a diary,
which I've never done,
in fact I did when I was in Sri Lanka,
but if I was,
if I'd kept a diary,
I maybe would have had a little bit more self awareness of my progression
through my career.
But when you'll,
you'll priorities are on earning money,
you know,
and,
and being able to pay the rent and am I going to get work next week or is that
other guy who's come in who looks quite good,
is he going to start getting my shifts?
You know,
and so you're constantly on your toes and you're not thinking and you think if I
get the,
the Northern Ireland Gig,
I got that and he didn't,
that's enough.
You know?
And that's how you were thinking.
You weren't really the,
I had no,
um,
structure to my career whatsoever.
Um,
and I think maybe because the whole thing was so new to me and I just couldn't
get my head around the fact that I was actually making your living as a
photographer.
Yeah.
And that's really a actually pretty similar to what I experienced on my first
deployment to Iraq where nevermind,
nevermind anything.
We were happy to be out doing operations.
Yeah.
Like we were going to go do real operations,
man.
We were,
what the strategy,
the,
the danger,
the whatever.
It was like,
Hey,
we are here.
We are doing operations to catch bad guys.
Awesome.
That was our focus.
Yeah.
So it sounds like you and the mindset that similar mindset and it's hard,
you know,
it took me a couple months of being in Iraq and getting that out of my system
before I was like,
okay so let's take a look at it,
but we're actually doing here and how we're trying to effect the battle space
cause I was just too young and inexperienced and I just need to get some
experience under my belt.
So sounds like it.
And really sounds like Ireland kind of prepares you for that.
But I also look at,
okay so,
so let's just go straight then two,
you get the call.
How did you know you got,
we're going to get the call to go to Iraq.
Was that,
was it a lottery?
How do they,
do they just say,
hey,
we want to get you down there.
How did that work?
Okay.
The,
the,
the way it works roads,
this was,
they um,
no photographer was ever forced to go to a hostile environment.
So it wasn't part of your remit that if you work for Reuters you must go to,
oh,
some of them,
they were never liked that.
Um,
they,
you know,
and you can see why
is it wrong for me to picture every for talk cause I had,
I put my,
I put my personality over a guy with a camera.
And so I think like every guy with a camera is going,
I want to go to the war zone tomorrow.
Is that not true?
No,
that's,
yeah,
that's not true.
There are a lot of guys that don't want to go anywhere near a Halston and
funner.
Okay.
Yeah.
See that's,
that's important for me to know these things because in my mind everyone's just
thinking,
I'm going to go get after it.
I'm old,
I got a camera,
there's a war going on.
Let's go make it happen.
Yeah.
I mean that was then,
that was,
yeah,
2003 I would say maybe,
maybe
it's slightly changed now.
There were a lot more photographers,
young photographers going to war zones,
but then no,
it was,
I think if I remember rightly,
they,
because the buildup to the wool was so,
you know,
prolonged.
I mean we knew it was going to happen and to re and immediately they were those
guys that wanted to,
that was one that embedded with the artillery in Qa.
So he had a month wait and Qa and then just went with yachts.
Hillary,
there were the Reuters had very seasoned,
uh,
photographers,
very experienced in those sort of environments that would then embed with
Americans or Brits.
And those were the guys that were being shot at on a daily basis,
but extremely hard to produce imagery from those situations.
Um,
on our member had a very good friend of mine said to me,
he did a lot of that stuff.
He said,
the Kirin thinking about going and embedding with the soldier is that,
um,
you can get in the way and the last thing you want is to compromise a unit.
But they set these units up and they said,
Yep,
the media has to come in.
And,
you know,
show us what's happening.
But most of the time he said,
you,
you have your head down and your hand in the air and you'll just blindly
shooting and hoping.
And he said in variable you get nothing.
You know,
I mean that's not always the case,
but he said majority of the time,
and you have to do it a lot before your sort of hit rate,
you know,
gets uh,
gets moved up.
And if you're embedded,
I think you struggle if you go unilaterally,
which is the really unsafe way to do it.
So you're on your own,
you're on your own and take pictures there.
You've got the chance of getting something and again,
it's being in the right place at the right time.
So they'd said they had certain guys in place that stuck their hands up straight
away.
Yup,
I'm doing that.
That's me.
I'll be embedded there.
Um,
and I'll do this and I'll do that.
And we spent a month looking at the stuff that was coming out and it was
invariably pictures of soldiers within sandstorms and stuff like that.
It was,
there was no action.
You know,
it was,
I wouldn't say that was true from all of them,
but the majority of the case,
it was very difficult to produce imagery when you're embedded.
Um,
I certainly wasn't interested in being a unilateral that time,
um,
at all,
but I was really interested in going and
doing what happens after the war.
So what interests me is the people afterwards,
I always tend to think that people go in and shoot what's happening and that
moves on and then the photographers move on with them.
And I wanted to just sort of go in that backdraft and photograph what was
happening lifewise after,
you know,
soldiers had been in there.
And,
and that's exactly what I said.
I said I'd be happy to go to Baghdad,
you know,
pretty much,
almost once it's secure.
It didn't quite work out that way.
I think led a little,
we went a little bit earlier.
It does,
does it?
Yeah.
And it never is as secure as you think.
And I remember,
I think I got the,
the,
the
day after the,
um,
the,
uh,
statue of Saddam was pulled down.
Right.
Um,
and it was,
um,
it was just,
it was a moment if you for you for Baghdad's.
And I just thought,
hey,
you know what,
this isn't,
I mean,
my first trip to Belfast was worse than this.
This is okay.
But we'd had,
but we turned up and had the faced with the problem of one of our cameraman had
just been killed under friendly fire and uh,
that had taken a huge hit on Reuters and that really hit home that actually this
is really not a safe place,
you know,
um,
because there's still an awful lot going on and there's still an awful lot of
misunderstanding and,
and so that was a real leveler when we got out there.
And,
um,
and staying in the Palestine Hotel was incredibly exciting because it was just,
there were just photographers and journalists and just buzzing around
everywhere.
And you know,
you were Theo cam here now,
so what am I going to do?
And it was almost as if I had to get out there and start shooting and I didn't
care what it was that I started shooting.
I just,
I'm here now.
I need to start shooting.
So that is the feeling that I had in my life.
Let's go.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and,
and I said to them,
I said to my,
the,
the chief photographer out there,
I said,
Jack,
what do you want me to do?
He said,
I don't know what cat into the square and see what's happening.
So I did.
And I walked out into the square and there were kids playing around in the,
in the,
in the main square and the fountain,
because you kind of go out,
and we were talking about this earlier today,
but you,
and you just said the word euphoric,
right?
And a lot of people,
because of the war in Iraq actually still going on right now,
but it's really easy to forget the initial,
I don't know,
four or five weeks after it started when we had crushed,
you know,
Saddam's regime and now the people were waving American flags.
The Iraqi people were waving American flags,
they were hugging,
they were,
they were happy.
And,
and it's really easy to forget that because things turned so bad,
really,
you know,
within,
within a couple months they'd turned bad.
Then they went down
from there.
Yeah.
But you were just like,
oh,
you know what,
I'm going to go out in the outside,
the Palestine who tell which is,
which is by the way,
across the river from the Green Zone,
but still was a very well protected,
you know,
fairly well protected a hotel that a lot of westerners who stayed in yeah.
And you just said,
oh,
I'm going to walk outside and check it out.
No security,
no security.
He was getting enough it.
Yeah.
Jess,
uh,
can I shoot and,
yeah.
And I,
and I,
I,
I found this picture of this kid and I still have that picture on my website,
but it's a little kid and he just pulls his head out of the Wilson.
He's swimming in this fountain.
Then you wouldn't believe what was in the fountain.
I couldn't believe these kids are swimming in it,
but he just sort of popped his head out and,
uh,
stood there and flexed his muscles.
And it was just a young nine,
10 year old guy just flexing his muscles and the light was fantastic and it just
made such a beautiful image.
I mean,
it really did.
And I thought,
okay,
I'll just go ahead and I've shot a really nice picture and I felt really proud
of myself on I thought,
okay.
And I just walked that back in.
And of course it was mayhem happening and what Reuters were actually doing was
in there in the process of moving out of the Palestine Hotel to,
um,
a house that they'd rented because we were then becoming quite a big outfit.
And the Palestine has held,
was never going to house it,
uh,
the amount of staff that we had.
So we were moving out to a big house just a couple of blocks away.
But again,
it was like Belfast,
I had got something under my belt and I felt pretty good about it and I thought,
okay,
right,
let's bring it on.
Um,
let's see how many places I can get to,
how many stories I can shoot,
um,
every day.
And I was,
I didn't want to stop shooting.
I just,
I want it to get up at seven in the morning and go and what with the light.
And then middle of the day was never really a good time to shoot because the
light was dreadful.
Um,
and then I'd wait for the sort of late afternoon and the Golden Hour,
uh,
which became tricky because we were never really allowed to be out at dark.
Um,
so I just want it to shoot,
shoot,
shoot.
And of course it doesn't quite work out that way because there were certain
responsibilities on a photographer whose first language is English.
When you go into,
uh,
a place like Baghdad where the,
the captioning on images is extremely important and it's extremely important at
the captioning is correct.
The information is correct,
it's a valid verified and it's has no spelling mistakes.
And of course,
being the only photographer there,
that first language is English.
I ended up wearing where are most of the photographers from what we had,
I mean all over Europe or if we had different,
you know,
and there was maybe only four,
four of us in there at a time,
three or four was in there at the time.
Um,
and I've got a French or guy,
a German Jaeger Croatian.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
and we were all looking for,
you know,
we're all,
we're all looking for those great pictures.
So in a you began to wonder,
okay,
how's this going to be divided up every day?
Who's going to get what,
you know,
am I going to get you looking for pictures at this point that are good pictures
that you want to see or you looking for pictures that are going to be news,
are going to be front page newspaper.
Which one of those two?
Or is it both?
Primarily,
if I'm completely honest,
because,
because a picture of like when you describe that picture of a kid pulling his
hat out of this dirty water,
he's 10 years old and he's flexing.
That's just an awesome image.
Right?
And I'm sure that's a great picture.
That picture is not going on the front page of newspapers though,
is it?
Absolutely not.
But you don't,
but,
but that's your focus is I want to get good pictures that are capturing the
images of what you're seeing around you as opposed to,
hey,
I just want this front page picture.
Yeah.
I mean I was never really one for looking for publications.
I was always shooting for mate.
I mean somebody wants to ask me in an interview,
who's your biggest audience?
I humbled me because that's who I'm shooting full.
Um,
so I'm not looking to please
editors,
whole whatever.
Obviously it helps if that helps with what you've done.
Yeah.
But I was primarily looking to satisfy myself and I've never,
that's never changed with me.
Um,
and so yeah,
I totally understand that.
You know,
when you're in a situation,
um,
I say that,
but obviously we'll get onto something like to that showed I completely didn't
understand.
But,
um,
I understand when this is the front page and I understand the impacts and I
understand what they mean to the company.
Totally.
And don't get me wrong,
when I was getting front pages,
it was a great feeling.
You know,
it sort of verified,
you're justified to find that you were out there and you were doing it.
Um,
but you know,
there are so many other agencies out there and so many other photographers out
there,
you have to get really lucky or you just have to get that one image that
separates it from everyone else.
And I knew how,
you know,
how difficult that is.
So I,
I never concerned myself with looking for that image.
I sort of began to think,
listen,
if I think the image is strong,
um,
you have a bit of confidence in your own ability to judge whether or not an
image is strong or not on whether or not it has a good chance of making.
So if you will not,
if it say,
listen,
this features today,
just go out and find something that,
you know,
every picture you shoes,
not going to tell the story of what's happening in Iraq.
But for me,
that picture,
that boy,
that day,
three days off to whatever bank that had been liberated now had a kid playing in
the water and looking,
feeling happy.
And I thought yet,
you know what,
that's what's happening.
That whatever's happening in Baghdad and now is being that child is a conduit if
we're capturing them.
Yeah.
Captures her lotion and the spirit of what's going on around here.
And that's,
that's,
that's a good overall I think attitude to have with everyone.
And you hear this all the time,
right?
He would say,
you know,
do what you're
go with your heart is basically what you're saying.
Absolutely.
And I,
and I'm an agreement with you,
I mean,
and again,
we've talked about this before,
even just with what we're doing here.
This is based on what we want to do in our toughest audience or our most
important audiences.
Like by us,
you know,
what do we want to do?
What can we,
how do we feel about making this and how does it feel to record it and how does
it feel when I put the headphones on and listen to it?
Isn't what I want to hear because that's what,
you know,
that song I'm doing it and we're doing it more for the value of itself rather
than,
I mean,
there's no doubt that we're not saying,
hey everybody listen to this.
You know,
cause
we know that this isn't for everybody and we're okay with that.
And I think that's a good attitude,
dad.
Yeah.
That's usually how it turns out the best anyway.
Because you know what you like and you know what's going to make what you like
good or look good.
Your case,
if you try to estimate what everyone else likes,
all you have is this,
like gray,
put brownish water.
You're not talking about just one other individual that you know really good.
You're talking about a bunch of people.
So a lot of times people,
and it turns out real obvious when they're trying to please other people with
what they're doing.
And she only goes for so many things.
Just like how you're saying.
Yeah.
So you know,
they're trying to basically play for the cheap seats.
They're trying,
you know,
they're trying to,
we talked about this where the goal should be doing a good job,
doing the best that you can do.
And we talked about it with Jujitsu,
with everything that the belt isn't the goal,
the front page,
that's not the goal.
The goal is to do the best that you can do for your work,
you know?
Yeah.
And like I said,
if,
if you,
if you don't do it that way,
man,
it just,
you can smell it from a Ma from either way,
man.
I mean,
I don't know that there are any,
apart from even even the image that did make all the front swabs in Iraq,
um,
I don't think in my career there's one image that's made front page that I would
keep and put in a portfolio of images.
So that just shows you that the stuff that I really like is,
is really the stuff that most people don't see.
And it's,
you know,
people will say,
Oh,
you shall that picture.
Yeah.
And I really liked that picture.
Um,
and I have really weird reasons for really liking that picture.
But the,
and that's the stuff that I really enjoy doing is most people never see that
stuff,
you know?
And they're surprised when they do see it.
But I,
there's,
I don't think there is a picture that I would take from a front page that I've
had,
um,
that I would want to keep and show.
And,
and that's one thing I know from,
from knowing you and things you've told me,
there's times where you're looking at a picture and you're saying there's a
tragedy here.
This is a person's life being destroyed.
I'm not going to sell this fixture,
I'm not going to publish this picture.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna delete this picture.
You know,
you,
you have your own personal standards,
which I have the utmost respect for that you're not going to,
I mean,
there's so many people in me,
especially now with social media and everyone's,
everyone's a photographer now now because everyone has an iPhone and people will
just shoot.
I mean,
there's whole websites that are dedicated to debasing people.
Right.
You know,
and,
and the fact that you're a professional and you,
you've drawn,
you drew that line a long time ago is very respectable.
MMM.
So you got some kids and you've got some nice things about the euphoria of Iraq
as it kicks off.
They're liberated.
And there's also some,
some horror mixed in there as well.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
just an a and it always comes when you least expect it.
and
we just moved into this new house in Baghdad and everything was set up an old
the are set up.
And um,
I knew it was about five o'clock in the afternoon and a call came in and the
cool just said,
a photographer and a
TV guy,
we need to get to this address in Baghdad.
And I was sitting there and Jack said,
Kiran,
you know,
off you go,
um,
and take,
take it obviously took a vest and the hat,
we always have the trouble with those.
And we traveled to down with vehicles everywhere.
So,
um,
we,
we went to this address and I sort of,
I got out onto the pavement and I was looking around and I,
I,
we had no idea.
We had no idea why we've been called.
And somebody came running up to me as soon as they saw the cameras and they
said,
are you the photographer from Reuters?
And I said,
yeah.
And they said,
okay,
wait here.
And they went to get,
uh,
a gentleman,
he,
and he came out and he was,
um,
I couldn't understand what he was saying.
And there was somebody there sort of translating.
Then it soon came to pass that his son had just been killed from,
he'd found an IED and he just been,
um,
it had just blown up while he was,
he and his friends were playing with it and it was the young,
it was a kid that was killed,
his son,
and I'm,
the father just had said something to the interpreter and the interpreter said,
listen,
can you wait?
He'll be back.
And he came back with a plastic bag.
And I wasn't even up up until that moment.
I would just wasn't aware of what was,
what was going on.
Um,
but I think the TV cameraman had sort of,
uh,
grasped the situation a little bit quicker than me,
and he started to,
uh,
produce body parts from the bag that was,
you know,
um,
uh,
they were unrecognizable as body parts,
but they were coming of this bag in and the interpreter saying,
he needs you to photograph this because he wants you to show the rest of the
world that his son was killed playing with an Iad.
And he doesn't want his son's death to be in vain and he can't start grieving
until you take these pictures.
And so I think I took six or seven pictures,
um,
and he ended up putting the plastic bag back down on the floor and he just said,
thank you.
And it was just shock run.
And he just,
then he walked in and the interpreter said,
now he can start to grieve.
And it was then that I noticed that the,
um,
the,
the TV a journalist,
the cameraman was,
he was Iraqi and he just completely
collapsed.
Um,
and I remember having to get him back into the car because what had the heat
just witness was just so shocking and I was just numb going all the way back to
the office because,
you know,
I,
I just hadn't anticipated anything like that happening.
And it just come out of the blue and I understood why I could understand the
father sentiments.
I totally got what he was trying to do.
But at the same time I totally understood that this,
you know,
those images weren't,
couldn't go on the why.
They were just so utterly horrific and graphic.
And I remember as I was shooting,
I just,
I wasn't even looking,
so I had my,
I remember my,
I was the camera,
but I wasn't even looking at what was,
you know,
sort of view apart from the first moment.
If you were to say to me,
you know what?
I couldn't tell you.
I just knew that it was just coming out and being held up and being put back.
I couldn't even bring myself to look.
And then I sort of got back and I,
the first thing I did was just delete.
And I never actually said to my bosses there that I've deleted those images.
I just thought,
I am not putting those images on the wire.
I sort of took an executive decision there and then at that time he didn't
mention anything to anyone else there.
And the only thing I had was that I kept,
was it just a portrait of the father so we could move the portrait of the father
and talk about the story.
Um,
and
I think I then spoke to my dad that night and I sort of
took the,
began sat phone and just writing him.
And I just told him what had just happened.
And we were sitting in the garden.
And then that,
um,
that night,
Reuters wanted to give the staff a,
and so they'd organized a barbecue and there was,
um,
you know,
there was going to be some,
there was,
I think a belly dancer turned up and it was an amazing night because all the
Iraqis that had not been able to party in 40 years,
we're all sitting on the roofs of their houses surrounding the house that we
were on.
And they were just listening to the music.
And it was an incredible thing to see.
But you'd gone from something that happened like that at five o'clock to
something,
a barbecue that was happening at 7:00 PM.
And those moments were incredibly difficult to sort of disseminate and work out
what was going on because,
and of course it was something I kept to myself apart from the,
I think maybe they find out maybe the TV journalist had said something,
but I just didn't want speak to anyone remotely connected to the office about
what had just happened,
you know.
Um,
and I do.
And I think,
to be honest,
they would've completely agreed that this is not imagery that we can put out,
you know,
it serves no purpose and it's just,
just not MGB that they would move.
So,
um,
so yeah,
there was,
there was plenty of that in Iraq and you sort of had to just take it in your
stride because the next day you'd be up and there'd be the next story and you'd
sort of move on to that.
But that would still be in the back of your mind,
you know?
And then do you know,
quite honestly soon enough,
you know,
if,
if you're busy and you're doing a lot of stuff when you're sitting around and
not doing anything,
that's when you really began to think about stuff.
But if you're busy and you're out and you're traveling.
So a week after that,
I would,
I was taking anything and he was,
even if I was being sent out on stuff that I thought,
ah,
why,
why am I being sent to do this?
You know?
Um,
I didn't mind.
I just thought I'll take it again better than
sitting around and just see with your own.
Totally.
I absolutely,
you know,
and um,
and it's also a weird,
and it's hard for people that they haven't been in a war zone before to
understand how things like what you're talking about this obviously everyone
anticipates or expects that there's the horror of war.
But then understand the barbecue part.
Let like that's a hard thing for people to understand that Yep,
you can be what does three months into this war and we've got the Reuters staff
having a staff party.
I mean,
okay.
Um,
people in America know what a little staff office party is.
Hey guys,
we're going to go,
we're going to order some pizzas.
They do that.
They do that in these war zones and,
and the military does it.
The,
the,
I mean,
I've talked about it a bunch.
these big basis that we had eventually built had subway sandwiches,
the company subway and the company Burger King and the company Starbucks were on
these bases.
So if you wanted to have a little subway party for your boys,
you could do that.
Fire up the grill,
have,
you know,
so it's really hard dichotomy for people to understand that inside the,
the protected areas,
we carve out little of America,
little chunks of freedom.
Did you take any pictures of what the Iraqi's looking at the party?
Yeah,
I did.
That must have been awesome.
But you know what,
they weren't great pictures
because
it was so dark and it was,
I took a few and I saw an under course.
There are other photographers there that were taking stuff as well,
you know.
Um,
so yeah,
I did.
And I,
I've always thought about that.
I remember those pictures,
but they didn't,
we didn't,
they weren't good enough.
I just,
I just didn't shoot it well enough.
You know,
I just didn't have the right lens and I just,
yeah.
And uh,
and I think that was the sort of,
uh,
you know,
um,
that might've been as a result of what had happened earlier,
but,
um,
yeah,
I have thought about that.
I have thought about those an f
and that remains with me.
It's a memory that I saw because I think,
you know,
it's like anything,
if you concentrate so hard on taking pictures,
you never actually take anything in.
But that was a moment that I really wanted to take in because it was just
incredible to see these people out on their roofs.
Just enjoying the music and not being afraid.
And you know,
somebody said to me,
this is not happened in 40 years.
And I just thought that was just incredible.
And those are the people that I talk about in ours.
I always end up trying to explain to people that there's the normal citizen.
Iraq is a normal person that wants to have a job and raise their kids and have a
house and that's what they want to do.
And it's really hard.
I mean,
America does a terrible job of showing that.
America media does a terrible job of showing what that is.
Nearly all you see is the crazies.
All you see is the extremists.
But that's a great example of people going,
hey,
you know what?
We've been oppressed for 40 years.
They're listening to music.
This is awesome.
Let's,
let's watch him.
And,
and,
and those are the people that wanted to take Iraq in the right direction.
Um,
that you did end up getting some pretty important or maybe not important,
well maybe important,
but you ended up,
uh,
with some,
some pictures that did end up on the,
on the front pages of yeah,
that's right.
Newspapers just right.
It was,
um,
coming off the back of another amazing story where the,
I'd been to nudge to follow,
follow a cleric who was coming back who'd been exiled 40 years before,
uh,
by Saddam.
And uh,
he was coming back to nudge Jeff and I spent two or three days down there
waiting for him.
And that whole scenario of him turning up with thousands of followers and being
pushed into the mosque,
cause I'm trying to photograph him and you know,
finding myself in the middle of a mosque as a westerner,
just thinking,
you know,
how did I get in here?
It was just,
you know,
and that's what happens when you stand in front of the door and wait for the guy
to turn up,
but you're just going to get taken in with them.
So,
um,
and I'd done that and I'd really enjoyed that job and this sort of anticipation
of waiting for this guy to turn up.
And it was an incredible moment.
Um,
and we would,
I'd left and of course in those,
in the days when I'd walked from the mosque in the draft back to the hotel,
which was probably a mile,
you know,
and I,
and those,
you didn't think twice had all my camera gear around me.
You just didn't think twice about walking down that street.
And we got back into our armored vehicle and we traveled back to Baghdad and
about three quarters,
the way that we got a call and it said,
you need to turn off to visit a mass grave has been found at Hiller and you're
on roots while you're going to pass it on the way back into Baghdad.
So can you stop off and have a look?
And my first reaction was I was so shattered from the four days in the job that
I was sort of slightly resigned about having to,
you know,
um,
really because we have to be back in Baghdad before it's dark.
And you know,
I just,
I had a really sort of ambivalent attitude to it.
So we,
we found this place when we pulled up and everyone said,
right,
hey guys,
you've got literally 40 minutes because we got to be out of here before the
sun's down.
So we got out and I just sort of walked over this mound and as I walked over the
mound that was here,
that there was just hundreds of bodies just laid out in front of me and they'd
been there.
I think it was probably about four or five days,
I think it was obvious how long they'd been there because you could see how many
bodies that they pulled out of the pit that they dug there.
And it was obviously an execution spot where I sit down.
I'd taken them,
I don't know how many years before,
and they'd all been executed a just a bullet to the back of the head,
all men.
And they were,
um,
they,
they dug them up and pulled the bodies out.
And I imagine the relatives had obviously had an idea of where they were,
but they were never able to do anything until,
you know,
they were in a position,
Baghdad had been liberated and they felt it was safe enough now to go and try.
And I think they knew sedan was on the run.
So,
um,
they were,
excavating this area and they'd found all these bodies and they put these bodies
into plastic bags and they had a name tag on each body.
And,
um,
that's when I realized,
okay,
this is,
um,
this is probably quite well,
this is bigger than any other mass grave that I'd shot,
um,
during my time there.
So I started shooting it and I knew the light was going down and the light was
incredible.
It was just incredible.
The lights on the sand and everything.
And I just started shooting and I started shooting the women that were sitting
around the edge behind the barbed wire.
So it obviously made the women sit round and then when they'd finished digging,
the women were able to walk through the bodies and try and identify to family
members.
And they were just picking up,
um,
id cards and you know,
trying to sort of figure out who was who.
And I remember there was one really bizarre moment where somebody had taken a
body what was remains of the skeleton and the corpse and they laid it out in the
shape of somebody just lying on the ground.
It wasn't a case of the remains were put into a plastic bag.
They had actually almost constructed this person as they were.
And so they were laid out and it looked like a person lying on the ground with
their arms out and their legs in the correct position and the head to one side.
And I just remember a young kid just walking past,
holding his dad's hand,
just staring at this.
And I thought,
that must be an unbelievable thing for a kid that age to be staring at.
And I remember taking that picture and it's,
um,
I remember thinking that is,
I,
I've never seen anything like that and I thought it was,
somebody has actually gone to the trouble of trying to do this and I couldn't
work out why.
And I thought life,
they done this,
you know,
I was pretty sure that it didn't help with the identification of that person,
but somebody had gone to the trouble of laying this,
this corpse out.
So I shot that picture and,
and I started moving around and shooting the women and the women were crying.
Um,
and I found,
I subsequently found out they were only,
they were crying because I had turned up with a camera.
So I had altered that situation and when they realize that I was no longer
interested in shooting them because they were,
they were crying because they thought this is what this photographer needs to
see.
Um,
yeah,
I just,
I,
they went back to playing with their dice and so I sort of moved away.
I thought,
well,
I won't be taking any more pictures of that.
Um,
yeah.
And just in and saw,
and they had,
and I know this isn't the right word,
but remind me Jocko,
what's the American version of a JCB?
Oh,
backhoe.
A backhoe.
So they had a backhoe in this pit pulling out the bodies and they had a couple
of kids underneath collecting the,
the remains and just put into one side.
Um,
and these kids were doing it as if it was just another day,
you know,
it was no,
it was impossible to see the,
if there was any shock or any,
you know,
they were just getting on with it.
They,
it was as if they knew this job has to be done,
so we're going to do it.
Um,
and it would just,
you know,
I remember seeing a skull roll off the,
uh,
the claw of this backhoe,
you know,
in this kid caught it.
He just called it like a goalkeeper would catch a football and they just put it
into a bag.
And uh,
yeah,
I watched that one.
I didn't actually shoot that one.
And,
um,
so it was a case of,
getting the job done as quickly as possible,
getting back in the van and getting back to Baghdad.
And I got back to Baghdad and I moved I think four or five images because I was
never really a person to move a lots of imagery.
I thought if I had some really good stuff,
I didn't want to dilute it with stuff that I thought was inferior.
So I just put the four or five best images out and was just hanging around.
When the,
uh,
the chief came in and he said,
listen,
how many pictures did you move of that story?
And I sit in that maybe four or five and he said,
when I see you better,
you better move some will because it's become the number one story in the world.
And I think there was over 2000 bodies they discovered at this place.
And of course I then thought cheese.
Okay.
Right.
And then I just sort of slightly panicked because I thought,
well,
I've just edited my stuff and I've moved five pictures,
what am I now going to find in there?
That's going to improve the file.
So I went through my,
you know,
my on my computer screen,
just going through the pictures and thinking,
you know,
I really wished that I'd spend a little more time shooting that moment because I
shut it and thought actually do you know I'm going to get something a bit
stronger than that in a minute.
So,
and I just,
and I sought and then I'd see another image and I work it through anything.
Okay.
I think the fourth image in this sequence is going to be the one.
And then I realized there wasn't the fourth image on.
I just kept saying no.
So what were you doing?
And of course at the time I had no idea that this was going to be the number one
story in the world.
And so I ended up moving,
I think I ended up moving maybe 15 pictures,
maybe more from this.
And every time I put a picture,
I thought,
you know what?
And it just so annoyed me that I hadn't maybe approached the job as in,
in the right manner.
I just had seen the light and I'd shot what I thought would be really strong.
And like I say,
you know,
in my career I miss as many pictures as I get.
In fact,
I miss more than I get and I can tell you about all the great pictures I didn't
take.
Um,
and that would make a great book.
but so I was just really angry with myself and angry that I'd had this
opportunity and I'd maybe blown it,
you know,
and I thought,
well,
this is why I'm here.
I'm here to shoot this.
I'm here to show the world that this is why this is what's happening and you
know,
and how could I have been so stupid as to not have concentrated a little bit
harder at while I was saying,
and I know we only had half an hour to 40 minutes,
but still I could have shot five times as much in that time.
But I didn't,
I just chose to meticulously walk through,
pick my moments and shoot them.
So we moved these pictures and fortunately the next day I think one of the,
I think it was an image of a woman in an uh,
walking past a skull that was just on,
I shot it from really low down on the ground and it was really,
it was an upright and that's what suited most of the papers is an upright image
of vertical.
And that was what got used on all the New York Times,
everywhere that just the Washington Post,
all the British newspapers everywhere around the world and run with this story.
And although we were the first guy there,
there were a couple of other photographers that were there at the time,
um,
with me,
but they didn't work for an international wire agency.
And that's the beauty about working for an international wire agencies that
their reach and their cloud is just phenomenal.
And it doesn't matter whether you're working for a newspaper,
but as soon as you work for an international wire agency,
particularly one as good as Reuters,
you,
you then realize,
actually when I've got this picture,
it's really going to get out there.
Everybody is going to see it,
you know,
and that's a huge buzz.
Um,
and it did and it made an,
it made the play was incredible.
And then my chief said to me,
okay,
can we,
you know,
where you're going back to tomorrow?
And again,
I thought,
well,
you know,
I've just,
I've just been there and I had pretty much the place to myself.
And I knew going down the next day when I drove there,
it was a zoo.
There was just every photographer and every cameraman in Iraq was a hiller and
you couldn't shoot anything without getting another photographer or a cameraman
or a sound boom because of the UN.
And there were,
I think I did take a couple of pictures that day,
some very strong,
a couple of strong pictures of a woman that had just discovered her husband and
she was surrounded by her family.
And the bane of every photographer's life is the sound man's boom.
And this woman was making this,
um,
she was,
it was just dreadful waiting.
I mean,
I still remember it now.
It was awful.
The noise she was making,
it was really guttural.
And,
um,
it really went right through you.
And I remember being really download and enclose and trying to photograph this.
And the next thing,
this furry boom just comes over at microphone and,
and,
and he's trying to record the sound.
And that's what it was like.
And you're getting annoyed at a sound man who's just stepped in and trying to do
something when you're trying to,
and you think,
and I'm getting annoyed with a guy who's trying to record a woman who's,
and the plumbing,
the depth of grief.
And I'm annoyed at him and I'm not thinking,
well,
listen,
what about her?
You know,
and in those situations,
you're not thinking about that.
You'll just,
I need to,
I need to shoot this picture.
So,
Yep.
Um,
the next day it was a zoo.
And,
uh,
but I was able to stand back and think,
you know,
um,
I got lucky that yesterday and I learned a really valuable lesson,
which is,
um,
it go into every situation like that as if you're never going to see a situation
like that again.
I mean actually even further back,
there was a chance that you could have,
I know we can't make
it,
we won't be home before dark,
so we're just going to head back Baghdad and of course,
but that's right.
But ultimately in that car that wasn't,
that probably wasn't going to be my cool.
So the somebody in the cow on,
I think I was with three or four others,
somebody at the,
maybe the journalists might've been the most senior in the,
in the,
in the OMD vehicle at the time.
And she would have made that colon.
She would have just said,
listen,
if this is what they want,
we need to go and do it,
you know?
So,
um,
Yep.
It came out okay at the end,
but it was,
that was close.
And I had a,
when I first,
when I was doing my first seal platoon,
my leading petty officer,
who is the senior will not even the senior,
but the second senior of the enlisted guys.
Anyways,
he had this,
this mantra and the mantra was always go out.
Now when he said,
always go out.
What he meant was always go out to the bar,
always go out,
you know,
you could,
you pull in somewhere for night,
go out,
you know,
that's always go out.
There's always some fun to be had.
And I actually,
my mind,
I always twisted that mantra from his,
always go out to go to the bar or go to the club.
I change it to just always go out period.
So if there's an opportunity,
there's an operation coming up,
we'll go out.
If there's a,
if there's a bar to go to go out.
If there's something to do,
go and do it.
It's just a little,
you know,
little something to think about.
I didn't remind when you're sitting there thinking,
you know,
maybe maybe wouldn't have been your call,
but if it was your call,
maybe you would have sloughed it off.
And if you had the attitude of Noah always go out,
okay,
yeah,
then you would have been their hunting percent.
Yup.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
and,
and
you get,
I don't want to cut Iraq short,
but at the same time,
there's so much stuff I want to talk to you about.
And hear other people talk about,
but you get home from Iraq and um,
you go back to your kind of normal day to day,
you said you were,
you know,
you saw some stuff,
but it wasn't like a major psychological effect that you noticed out of the
gate.
You came home,
Hey,
that was my job.
I did my job.
Um,
next call you get big call is to go to Sri Lanka,
which you mentioned briefly there.
And in Sri Lanka you were going,
because of the horrible tsunami that hit on boxing day and Americans don't know
a boxing day is,
it's a day after Christmas and New England hit on boxing day and you get the
call to go out to Sri Lanka and shoot.
Yeah,
that was,
um,
I remember the,
the,
um,
the desk working on boxing day
called me and I was running up my parents with my kids and we were all just
about start opening Christmas presents.
And,
um,
she said,
Karen,
you need to get on a plane.
He needs to go to Colombo.
This leak,
um,
straight away.
And I said,
why?
And she said,
well,
I'd be no hurt.
And I said,
I heard what she said,
turn on the TV.
So I turned on the TV and uh,
yeah,
it was like a nine 11 moment.
You know,
when you're sitting in,
you're looking,
you just think
I had no idea.
And,
and by the way,
just to,
just to kind of give some basic facts on this,
the tsunami that hit the Indian Ocean had the approximate energy of 23,000
Hiroshima atomic bombs.
It was a magnitude 9.0 the rupture was 600 miles long.
It displaced the c four by 10 yards,
600 miles,
10 yards.
So,
uh,
trillions of trillions of tons of rocks moved.
It's the largest earthquake and 40 years.
And within hours the,
the killer waves started arriving.
And unfortunately,
because of lack of communication and no warning systems in place,
people were just not,
they weren't prepared for it throughout Asia.
And they just got crushed.
Absolutely crushed.
And,
uh,
you know,
you,
you said a nine,
11 moment,
which I understand where you're coming from,
from a psychological standpoint of,
hey,
well I know what I was doing at this point on September 11th,
well,
September 11th was 4,000,
maybe 5,000 Americans killed the tsunami,
resulted in almost a quarter million den.
I mean,
just a massive destruction and
you got the call.
So you got the call.
And it just happened to be because I was the guy on call.
Oh,
okay.
Boxing Day.
So it could have gone to any photographer in London.
Um,
so,
and they,
they Reuters had sort of,
there were,
there were photographers that have gone to panda at j and,
and other places and they needed somebody to go to Sri Lanka because they,
they had an idea that shrank had been pretty badly hit.
And because it was my name on the scared for boxing day,
that's why I got the call.
And I ended up going out the following,
I think it was the 27th I flipped out.
And,
uh,
yeah,
it just one of those stories where you have to hit the ground running.
So you're off the plane,
you get through customs and you're straight to a car and you're into the office
and you're speaking to the bureau chief there and you say,
right,
I'm here.
So where am I going?
And they are still trying to figure what's happened and where the,
you know,
the the most severe damages and pretty much,
most of the coastlines of Sri Lanka had been hit.
So it didn't really matter where you went.
You were always going to find something.
So they were trying to,
I said,
I really want to get over to the other coast.
I don't want to get over to this,
stay here where all the tourists come.
I want to get over to the other side.
So we will literally try to find a helicopter that would get me straight over
there.
But in the meantime,
while they were trying to work that out,
I just got in the car and I just drove down from Columbia,
just straight down through goal to just see what was going on.
And again to get something under my belt.
And I just started shooting,
um,
and then came back to the office.
Had you ever been in Sri Lanka before?
I'd never been.
Srilanka No.
Um,
so,
uh,
go back to the office and I said,
listen,
um,
what's happening with the chopper?
And they said,
well,
you know,
it's not really happening but there might be a government minister that's going
to go across.
So myself and a journalist got in the car and we went to the government
ministers office and um,
he was going to get an a chopper and get over to the other side.
They have the coastline.
But before he did that,
we were going to sit down and have lunch.
I was just thinking,
I can't listen.
Do you know what?
I really didn't want to sit here and have lunch.
Um,
why don't we just get in that chopper and kept going.
But we had this,
I had to go through this whole rigmarole and um,
and then eventually we got to the chopper and we got up for about three minutes
and a storm front came in,
chopper came back down.
So that was that avenue of getting across and we would have been there in an
hour.
So we had to work out another way.
So we,
uh,
we drove to candy,
um,
in one of those,
uh,
we,
we found a car guy who drove us from Columbia,
drove us all the way through the center of Sri Lanka to candy.
And we got to candy.
And I remember that was New Year's eve when we got there,
myself from the journalist.
And the coincidentally and the journalists that was with me,
she was flying back from a holiday and she'd heard about the tsunami and she
stopped off in Sri Lanka.
She was a lobby journalists that worked for Reuters.
But,
um,
so she was used to dealing with the politicians.
And,
um,
she just said,
listen,
I'm a generalist and I need to,
this is a story that I need to cover.
Um,
so she came in and she said,
listen,
you know,
and I knew her on,
I said,
wow,
what are you doing here?
And she said,
well,
I,
you know,
can I be of help?
So I said,
let's go,
you know,
and we got in this car and we went,
um,
and she had such an amazingly fresh take on a story like that,
purely because she was used to covering lobby in and,
uh,
back in the UK.
And because she wasn't a seasoned sort of,
I dunno,
a hostile environment,
journalists,
the way she would write stories and find stories was just like,
you just wouldn't have got it from,
uh,
you know,
she just had a completely different angle on it.
So it was so refreshing to work with someone who just saw everything from a
completely different viewpoint.
Everything was new to her.
But that meant that her writing and everything was really fresh and vibrant,
you know,
so she was an absolute pleasure to work with and we sort of just teamed up and
we got to the other side and as soon as we got to the other coast,
it,
it flooded the whole area flooded,
which meant no one could get in to that side of sure.
Lincoln.
And we had that place to ourselves for over a week and we were staying in a
hotel where the floors were just two feet high in water.
I mean,
but they still manage to get us rice every night.
it was just incredible how these people just manage.
And of course you get out there and your
[inaudible] right,
where do we go?
So let's just walk down to the coastline and,
and let's just see what the situation is.
And of course you go down as a,
um,
as a Westerner and,
and these people just think that your,
you can help them.
So they're coming up in there,
showing the documentation in their passports and can you take this to the
American embassy and can we get off the country?
And I have,
I have relatives that live in the UK,
in relatives that live in America and I can leave.
And,
and,
and he knew you.
I've never felt so helpless in my life.
Never felt so helpless.
And I spent a fair amount of time in Sri Lanka back in,
back in the day.
And the Sri Lankan people are just the nicest.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Hindest Reuben,
hardworking.
I mean,
it just,
it's just a beautiful,
and the countryside itself is absolutely stunningly beautiful.
And so,
so I can imagine them doing,
going,
jumping through hoops and doing whatever they had to do to get you a bowl of
rice when you came home at night and get ahead of them.
And then you would meet the people
that were living on the beach.
Uh,
the homes were on the beach and they'd been hit by the wave and
they would just immediately,
immediately rebuilding.
It was just,
okay,
listen,
this is what we've got to do.
And they start rebuilding and I'll never forget wandering round.
Um,
at that point on the,
on the tip on the eastern tip,
and I found,
uh,
just there was a wall,
just a wall left of a house.
So I imagine it was the wall where there was the door and everything else had
gone.
It was one brick wall just standing up zone.
And if you sort of walked through this door,
you just saw golden sand and palm tree and there was a dresser,
just a one wooden dresser against this back wall.
And the young guy came up to me and he'd said,
he said,
hey,
um,
you photographer,
and where are you from?
And the,
you know,
the usual.
And I sort of got chatting to him and,
and he said,
can I get you a drink?
And said,
listen,
I'm fine.
Seriously,
don't worry about it.
I'm,
I'm absolutely fine,
but thank you.
He said,
no,
no.
Listen,
I can run to the store,
which was about a mile inland.
Yeah.
And I can get you a diet coke or a coke,
whatever it is.
I said,
please listen,
I'm,
I'm seriously,
I'm absolutely fine.
He said,
okay,
well please sit.
And he pulled up at crate and we just sat it down and I'm sitting in what used
to be his main room of his house and he puts,
let me get to the crate and lets me sit on it.
And then he just shimmies up the coconut tree and he just pulls a coconut off
the top of the tree.
Shimmies back down.
And I'm thinking,
and I really don't like coconut milk.
I mean,
cause it really,
it doesn't agree with me.
So I just thought,
oh,
okay,
but you know,
he's going to this effort so he can't down this.
And he took the top off and then he went to the dresser and he opened the drawer
and he pulled out a tiny silver platter and he put the coconut on the platter.
And then he handed it to me.
Um,
I need even got a straw and he put a straw in it and he said,
please,
you know,
you're in my home and I'm looking at the one wall is left of his home with his
dresser.
And so I take a sip of this drink.
And I said,
so tell me what I mean if this is your home,
the Dev,
I mean,
you know,
the water was 25 feet away.
There's the golden sand.
I said,
what happened?
And he sort of,
the wave came in and destroyed my house and it took away my parents,
my wife,
my brothers and sisters and my six kids,
they're gone.
And all I can think of is that he has tried to find somewhere for me to sit.
He's going up a tree to get me a coconut and put on a silver platter.
The only thing that's left in his house is this chest of drawers or a stressor
with its silver platter in it.
And he's more concerned about my welfare at that moment.
And this is what had happened to him about five days earlier.
And I remember thinking when I got back from Sri Lanka,
I couldn't stop thinking about that conversation.
And I think that was the time when it really hit me.
It really hit me about what had happened and I can't even begin to describe.
I think I had a numbness similar to their sort of numbness that I'd had in Iraq,
but this was a different kind of numbness because the thing about the tsunami
was you were dealing with the living and it was the living that affected you.
It wasn't the death and it wasn't the,
the bodies that have been swept a mile inland and ended up in people's houses
and stuff like that.
It was,
it wasn't the,
the,
you know,
you
would cover the funerals of all the different religious types there.
You just,
it's when you're speaking to the people that survived that you,
it's a,
it was a real,
a real level in a and m
well that just about sums up my,
you know,
that story about that guy.
I mean,
first of all,
anybody that hears that story
has to think to themselves,
you know,
oh,
am I really doing the best I can to number one,
have a positive attitude.
Number two,
put other people before me.
I mean,
what a,
what a what a saint.
I mean,
that's just unbelievable.
And I remember actually as you were telling that story,
I remember that when I was in Sri Lanka,
there was guys that,
you know,
they'd been fighting a war against the Tamil Tigers for many years.
And so that's who we were working with these guys.
And they would,
they would be telling these war stories with any,
it'd be showing you,
you know,
there's a guy that couldn't move his arm,
right?
He got shot in the arm with an AK 47 so now he was working as well as like a
secretary in the,
in the army.
And he's just got this big smile on his face and he's telling me,
yeah,
you know,
and,
and I,
I got shot and how my arm doesn't work.
But,
um,
you know,
being a secretary is a pretty,
a pretty good job too.
And it's just good to still be in the army and you just have this,
this,
uh,
this feeling,
it probably the similar feeling that you have.
We're just looking at these people and you're saying,
how can you be so happy?
Yeah.
And why can't I be there?
I want to be that happy.
But this is,
it's just so impressive and it puts everything in so much perspective when we
hear about somebody that's lost that much that's going to climb that tree that's
going to climb that tree for somebody else,
even though they've lost everything themselves is a humbling.
So,
so credible.
Yeah.
So did you,
when you,
when you came home and you,
you know,
you told me about this earlier,
um,
and you were just kind of getting into it.
I mean,
you felt like after Sri Long,
you know,
you go to Iraq and you see the war and that's,
that's one thing.
And like you said,
you're dealing with the dead and you're seeing people that were killed,
but now you're dealing with the what's left behind it and you said that that
really had more of an impact on you then,
then I racked it,
or the Northern Ireland did.
Yeah.
Did you,
how did you,
how did you deal with that?
Well,
the Reuters policy is that,
um,
when,
when you arrived back from a situation like that,
your line manager hands you a number,
you know,
quite discretely and says there's a number there if you need to call it.
Um,
and it's a sort of a helpline.
He knows sort of you've talked to a professional about what you've been through
and it's sort of way of imagining the RTB,
that debrief.
It's sort of a thing that they just sort of,
you get that you start to talk about what it is you,
and I don't know.
I've
never been in a situation like that,
so I don't know what happens,
but I remember thinking,
I'm fine.
I don't need that.
That's cool.
Um,
so,
uh,
again,
I couldn't have been more wrong.
And,
um,
I ended up,
I had nightmares for,
I mean,
maybe a couple of years off too.
It's really,
really bizarre nightmares that involved cameras and involved tidal waves.
I mean,
the,
the sort of the mix that was going on.
I mean,
if,
I suppose if I was to sit down and talk to professional about it,
they,
they might find it really interesting what was going on in my head.
But I had to,
I came back really angry.
I remember coming back really angry,
um,
for the main reason being that I was coming back to my comfortable home and
I thought about those millionaires living on the riverbank in London.
And I thought,
well,
what if it happened?
If the Thames suddenly when they just completely sorted the berries broke and
just water,
just
how would the athlete,
you wouldn't,
you wouldn't know where to start.
You just wouldn't know what to do.
And you sit and these people,
you know,
we have lots of floods in England now.
Um,
and what people go through,
I can understand is completely and utterly miserable,
but that the carpets are being ruined and,
and all this sort of stuff.
And um,
Yep.
I wouldn't want to go through that.
But you know,
when you,
when you compare that to what happens during a tsunami,
it's just night and day.
It really is.
And so I got angry about coming back to live in a comfortable house and I used
to get angry that my seller flooded in Stratham where I lived.
I had a big seller where I had my drum kit and it flooded once.
And,
um,
my wife,
Tia,
she was down there with my daughter and she was,
ended up pulling my drum kit out of three or four inches of sewage water that
had come into,
you know,
and,
um,
I'm responsible for her hurting her back because she should never have done it.
But she was trying to get my,
all my equipment off the floor.
And I remember being so angry that my seller had flooded.
And then you go to someone like Sri Lanka and you think,
actually,
come on,
let's put this in perspective.
Um,
so yeah,
the anger,
I,
and I think it took a while to maybe if I take in my line manager's advice and
wrong that phone number,
I might've been in a different place and it might have had,
you know,
I might've got to a different place a lot quicker,
but I didn't.
And I thought I can handle this.
And,
um,
and even while I wasn't handling it,
I didn't know I wasn't handling it.
You know,
I just thought this is normal that you come back from these events and just yell
at your wife who's dealing with three really small kids and there's you in one
ear.
Uh,
you know,
given all this about your dreams and you know,
flooding and this and that.
And I'm really annoyed and I should have stayed out there longer.
And why did they bring me back so early?
I had so many other stories lined up.
And,
uh,
and of course,
you know,
it then dawned on me,
that actually,
um,
my wife was my psychiatrist.
And to be fair,
she wasn't actually having to say anything.
She was just listening and it was a case of me needing to just get all this
stuff off my chest and I would just pick the bizarre as moments to do it,
you know?
Um,
but some of would pop into my head and,
and,
and then,
you know,
I'd have friends round and something would set me off on Id and another thing,
and it was a bit like that.
Um,
so yes,
I would say if maybe I'd been sort of clinically diagnosed,
they would have said,
you're suffering from some post traumatic stress.
Um,
and I didn't experience that after Iraq.
And I don't know why.
I think maybe it was because I thought of war as completely different to what
you would maybe categorize as an act of God.
So,
um,
that in a way I found quite interesting or was what happened when I got back
from the tsunami,
a culmination of what happened in Iraq.
But I'd been to Iraq and at the end in between Iraq and the tsunami,
I had spent nine weeks in Australia photographing the rugby World Cup and that
was a pretty good gig and I'd had a great time.
So there was that sort of huge job in between these other two huge jobs.
And I'm wondering maybe the,
the distraction yeah.
Had,
had,
had helped,
you know,
maybe I was too busy thinking about something else.
I was nine weeks on a tour in Australia and amazing country having a great time
shooting the Rugby World Cup,
which England and went on to win.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it was um,
I don't know.
I really until this day,
I'll never know.
But um,
yeah,
dealing with that and it was interesting cause I was working for the BBC in
Dubai,
uh,
in 2010 and I was working with a producer,
um,
and there was a series called human planet and I was out there shooting stills
for the book that was going to come out with the series.
And we were out with this falconer in Dubai,
a South African guy with a f who trained for,
and that it was the end of the shoot.
And then we were out and we were having a meal and the producer asked me,
he said,
oh,
care.
And you've got some,
you know,
um,
incredible stories.
Why don't you tell him the story about the tsunami?
I thought,
wow,
that's a really bizarre thing to start about at the end
of a meal where we're celebrating finishing a shoots.
But I obliged and I met,
I can't even remember.
I started talking and that just the whole table just went
awesome.
Silence.
I mean,
they were in thrilled.
But,
uh,
in the end,
the producer came up to me afterwards and he said,
I'm really sorry the,
I asked you to talk about that because he said,
I can see that every time that you must talk about it,
you lose a piece of yourself.
You,
you know,
it's so entrenched in you that when you talk about it,
you're giving part of yourself away.
And he said,
and I really apologize for putting you in that position.
And that had never occurred to me that was happening.
But he could tell that by watching how I was talking about it,
you know,
I don't know if that's the case now,
but I don't tend to talk about it purely because it was 2004 and you know,
a lot has happened between then and now.
And so it's not something that I sit down with on a regular basis and talk to
people about.
So,
but I can imagine that even now,
probably at some point it's probably just a tiny bit,
maybe similar,
but not like it was closer,
but that was 2010 that was six years afterwards and he's still spotted that it
was,
you know,
still very high in my sort of psyche.
Yeah,
I think it's,
I think it's somewhat therapeutic to talk about it.
Yeah.
And,
and I think the more you talk,
if that guy asked you the same question once a week and you told that story once
a week and you got more in depth with it and got her hands wrapped around it,
I think that's good for you.
And you know,
they talk about that too.
Uh,
the though the veterans and World War Two,
when you,
when you came home from World War II,
first of all had been at war for three or four years and when you came home you
got onto a ship with a bunch of other guys that just did what you did.
And what did you do?
You talked your talk through stuff,
you told stories,
you're cried,
you let it out.
And by the time they got home,
two weeks later,
they just had this therapeutic session.
Right.
And that's why they said that these guys recovered a lot better.
Well,
in Vietnam,
you're in the middle of the war and then one day your tourists up of 365 days
you get on a plane and 24 hours later you're sitting in mainstream USA.
You didn't debrief anybody,
you didn't talk to anybody in the way home.
You're just went from that environment to,
to the normal environment.
And it has my,
one of my sequel buddies,
you said one time,
I can't believe in 24 hours we're going to get inside of an aluminum tube and
then we're going to be back home.
And,
and that's true.
So,
uh,
I think if you can find your friends are,
or people that you can talk about these things with,
it helps you.
And,
and that's what you said too,
when you told Tia,
lovely wife what was going on.
That's how it,
all she did was listen,
she didn't have to,
she didn't,
oh,
she,
all she had to do was listen and let you explain those thoughts.
Yup.
Um,
rough.
And then the next big assignment,
and I,
you know,
we've talked about a bunch of different things that you've done,
but one of the things,
and I always get drawn to things that I know a little bit about or something
that I've seen.
Um,
and,
and I know that you ended up going to Liberia as well.
And I did.
I was on standby.
I was actually off the coast of Liberia in the late nineties when things were
just going to completely sideways and I pulled up a
little article that captures some of the madness that was going on in Liberia.
This is an article from the Guardian by Chris McGreal,
the Guardians,
a UK site,
a commander in Charles Taylor's.
Charles Taylor's,
malicious of Charles Taylor was this psychotic dictator of Liberia.
Militia has told a war crimes trial that the former Liberian president ordered
his fighters to eat their enemies,
including UN peacekeepers as a means of terrorizing the population.
Joseph Zig Zag Marza chief of operations for Taylor,
who is on trial at the Hague also testified that he oversaw horrific crimes such
as cutting the babies out of pregnant women and that the former president told
his men that their enemies are no longer human beings.
Taylor 59 has pled not guilty to 11 counts of war crimes and crimes against
humanity had a special international court over his collaboration with
antigovernment revels in Sierra Leone,
which borders Liberia.
Marza.
This is his chief of operations who led the death squad of group.
Group of killers said many of the victims of cannibalism.
We're members of the chron people of the then Liberian President Samuel Doe,
who Taylor was attempting to overthrow,
but those Eaton also included soldiers from UN and west African Echo mog
peacekeeping forces.
He said we should eat them.
Even the UN white people.
He said we could use them as pork to eat.
Marza told the court we ate a few ECAM mog soldiers,
but not many,
but many were executed about 68 he said,
Taylor said,
eating people set an example for the people to be afraid.
Taylor's defense lawyer asked Marza how the fighters would prepare a human being
for the pot.
The former commander described decapitating carving up cleaning and cooking.
Corpse is with salt and pepper.
We slit your throat,
butcher you throw away the head,
take the flesh and put it in a pot.
Charles Taylor knows that said Marza.
He told the court how rebel leaders who fell out with Taylor Mehta,
terrible end,
the former commander describe dismembering,
the body of another rebel leader known as Superman and then taking his hand to
Taylor who gave him cigarette money in return.
Yeah,
Marissa said the pair then cooked up an eight Superman's liver.
Marissa said that he'd killed so many men,
women and children.
He had lost count.
He described drowning and bludgeoning babies to death and murdering women with
pen knives.
He said when he was serving Taylor's rebel,
National Patriotic Front of Liberia,
he'd established checkpoints on roads using human intestines and severed heads
mounted on sticks.
Asked whether Taylor knew about this.
Marza replied,
he was aware.
He made us understand that you have to play with human blood so that enemies
would be afraid.
Asked how he felt about these actions.
Now Marza said,
I regret nothing.
Sorry.
I apologize.
That is,
that is our lifetime.
That is me.
This is me sitting off the coast of Liberia.
While this was happening,
heinous.
Just,
okay.
It's just sick.
And,
and,
and I think,
you know,
Taylor was overthrown in 2003.
Obviously the country still bears the scars of that kind of
darkness and evil in.
And that's something you talked about earlier was the fact that your
perspective,
and this is what I think I find very interesting about your perspective,
is that I'm always talking and exploring and studying the point of war where
it's happening and you end up in these places.
Maybe you're a day behind,
maybe you're a week behind,
maybe you're a foot behind,
maybe you're a mile behind,
but you're seeing what the after effects of war is.
And
I think that that perspective for all of us to know is very important.
So,
and I know you were there while you were there.
Again,
I though you were there and what year?
2012.
Yeah.
So this is,
I mean,
it was never,
it's never exactly,
uh,
going to be the most peaceful place in the world,
but it was relatively stable compared to when it was under Taylor.
Yup.
MMM.
And I'll tell you what,
this is one thing that,
yeah,
when I,
when we,
when we were off the coast of Liberia and you're looking at the coast and you
can see the customer,
we were,
we were literally maybe a couple of miles off shore looking at the coast and I
can see that there's waves breaking.
So I'm kind of thinking,
you know,
I'm a surfer,
I'm thinking,
Hey,
you know,
those look like good waves.
And then you can see there's buildings,
nice big kind of hotel.
You can see this beautiful white beach.
You can see it looks like a just beautiful place.
I'm thinking to myself,
I need to go here on a,
on a surf trip.
And then eventually,
you know,
I'm looking at us for a few hours,
we get a little bit closer.
I'm starting to make out a little bit more what I'm looking at.
And eventually I get out the big giant optics to,
to study where we might be landing in,
what's going on there.
And when I look through these optics,
the whole picture changed because now you see all these buildings that look like
they literally look like big,
beautiful,
you know,
beach.
Um,
what's,
what's a big beach hotel called,
uh,
on a Surf Reddit?
Yeah.
Something like the marijuana surf.
Right.
But these big resorts,
they looked like these big giant resorts.
And as I put the big optics on them and sort of looking at all the,
they're just completely gutted.
They're destroyed.
It's just a nightmare.
And
it's so horrible to see such a beautiful place just completely destroyed by us,
by humans,
by fellow human beings have just completely destroyed it.
MMM.
What did you notice or what did you,
what did you,
what was it like when you were there?
Give us a debrief on 2012.
Um,
I mean,
I,
I just,
when you mentioned those hotels,
I remember taking a trip out to the beaches and just walking along the beaches
for a couple of miles and just looking at these places,
thinking was gone here.
I mean,
my overriding,
eh,
the country was just eviscerated.
I mean,
and it's still,
um,
I mean,
I was there working for an Ngo and there were certain areas and certain things
that they wanted covered.
Um,
and I have the opportunity on a,
on a couple of days to basically just go unilateral on it and just take it a
fixer and just go and do my own stuff.
And,
um,
on that particular trip,
that's when I actually shot the pictures that I thought were really quite
interesting,
um,
from that.
But that was,
that was looking at,
um,
sort of Liberia as a whole,
but I was only in Monrovia,
but I had this picture of,
I mean,
we traveled down to the river g county and grand ghetto.
just stunningly,
stunningly beautiful parts of the country.
I mean,
just ridiculously beautiful.
Um,
and the sort of,
the difference between living in the country and maybe living in Monrovia was,
was,
was so tangible.
I mean,
Monrovia was,
it's the,
the infrastructure has just completely disappeared.
And I can't remember the figures,
but I just remember being blown away by the fact that the town was built for
say,
hypothetically,
a million.
And it was something like 5 million living in it.
I mean,
those figures aren't correct,
but it's,
it's that sort of scale that was just mind blowing.
Um,
and it was such a shame because it's such a,
it's such a beautiful country.
The,
uh,
Liberians are such beautiful people and yet you,
you,
you had this overriding sense that are they ever going to escape this?
Is this the legacy?
Is it going to stay with Liberia?
Are they,
are they ever going to be able to pull themselves out?
They are such a poor country.
Um,
and I remember looking at areas where money was being spent on,
I was asking myself,
why,
why are you spending money here?
Why are you making the roads outside the mayor's office look pristine when the,
the,
the inside of Monrovia is the state that it is.
There's the West Point slum,
I think,
which is one of the biggest slums there.
And,
um,
and I remember walking through that and I never once felt intimidated.
Um,
these were just incredibly vibrant places,
but the conditions that the people were living in that version of normality was,
um,
a camera really couldn't tell that picture.
He just couldn't,
he just couldn't shoot those images to tell that story properly.
I think,
you know,
it's one of those rare times when I've had a camera in my hand.
I think I,
I,
I can't tell this story with,
with a camera.
I don't know what I can tell it with,
but I can't tell it with the camera.
It's because the,
the,
the conditions or so,
yeah.
So,
so dreadful.
And I mean,
the way Monrovia is,
there's built,
it's sort of slightly on a hill and,
and,
and it rains a lot in Liberia.
And what happens is the rain falls off the concrete and when it rains,
excuse me,
it really rains and it creates just torrents.
And these torrents just drop off the roads of Monrovia and they go down into the
slums and they hit the slums before they hit the c and the s and the slums or,
uh,
I mean,
um,
that they flood at certain times of the year.
And yet the people are,
they expect it,
they know going to happen.
So I'm spending some time in,
in west point slum with,
um,
a young man and his family and he is a,
a health advisor and he has two daughters and they both want to be doctors and
he is describing the,
the conditions that they're living in,
um,
and what they have to go through every day.
And I mean,
you can,
especially if you're walking through Monrovia,
you can see the sanitary conditions in the laboratories.
There is just,
it's,
it's beyond belief.
It really is.
And,
uh,
you know,
there are,
there are latrines that go straight into the river and that just corrugated
latrines with a door and you just go in and,
and,
and the sewage goes straight into the river and it's three feet away.
The kids are just playing around in that river,
the way our kids would play around in a swimming pool,
no idea of what is going through their systems.
Um,
and,
and of course when you catch something like dysentery or typhoid or that they're
one of the biggest killers of kids in Africa,
um,
and,
and you look at it and you think,
how this is such a vicious circle,
how are they going to,
are going to come out of this?
How are they ever going to find a way to lift themselves up because it's such a
poor country,
but they sort of make do with the situation that they're in.
And then the slum floods and they say,
oh yeah,
it's gonna Flood.
And although wis were four feet off the ground and we've got steps coming up to
our,
you know,
it's going to flood and it's going to come in.
So we have to just put what we sleep on.
Little stilts,
you know,
but they're getting up in the morning and stepping into it and coming out.
And then,
you know,
they don't have Wellington's,
they just wade their way through it.
And this goes on for,
and he said,
uh,
I was there in August and he said,
well,
you should be here in September.
This is nothing.
Um,
and so I was away from,
I'd sort of detach himself from the NGO at the time and I just went,
so gene Latin and I just wanted to photograph.
I just wanted to try in some way to explain what it was I was looking at and I
wasn't shooting it for anyone in mind.
I mean,
the Ngo take all my images.
Um,
they,
they have,
they have access to all my imagery that I shoot,
whether I'm shooting it for them or whether I've just gone off piece,
so to speak,
to shoot.
So they get absolutely everything.
Um,
and I was trying to find a way to document what it was that you could see.
And,
um,
I was really struggling until there was one moment when
I was wandering through the slum,
the flooded slum,
and I was up to my knees and sewage as we're walking through between the
corrugated huts.
And there was a little flash of pink in front of me.
Um,
and I saw this young girl sort of just go between two buildings and she was
carrying a pink umbrella.
And I remember thinking
there's another picture of mist.
So,
um,
I asked the young doctor who was accompanying me through this time,
I said,
you know,
what's the deal?
And he said,
oh,
she's probably off to church or something,
you know,
cause she's in her Sunday best effectively with a perfect little shoes and had
skirt and her pink umbrella.
Um,
so I thought nothing of it carried on shots and more pictures.
And I thought,
actually,
I've got it.
I've got quite a lot of stuff here.
None of it.
I was really thinking this is really strong,
you know.
And then on the way back to the car,
I saw the little flash of pink again in front of me and it disappeared.
And I thought,
well,
this time I'm not,
I thought giving up.
So I just started to run through this.
You know,
and you can imagine if you're running through two foot of sewage,
well it's not the greatest site in the world and you're trying to stop your
cameras from going in and you're trying to it.
And there's a couple of times I nearly went headfirst in,
but I was so desperate to try and take a picture of this.
And my image I had in my head was when,
when she comes back through that corridor and comes back into this main corridor
that I mean of water,
I'm going to just shoot her from behind like a Mary Poppins type of picture.
And the contrast for me was this beautiful little girl in this situation,
in this with a pink umbrella in this horrendous slumps situation.
And there she was.
And by the time she disappeared again,
I just thought,
this is just really not my day.
And then she'd obviously heard me running and she sort of popped out again and
just turned around.
And it was almost like a little bank of sand that she was standing on between
two huts and there was about a foot and a half of water in front of her.
And she just turned around and looked at me as if,
yes,
w w what do you want?
And I just took one picture and click and that was it.
And the second I took the picture,
she just turned on our heels and just walked off and tip toeing her way.
There was me in the middle of this,
you know,
so,
but she was finding these delicate way around just like Mary Poppins with,
you know,
um,
and I didn't really,
so I thought,
okay,
I hope that sharp because I'm shooting on a manual focus lenses.
And you know,
when you've got one shot at it,
you just really hope that you got it sharp,
you know?
Um,
uh,
because I had been in that situation when I've had one shot at it before,
I'm not going to sharp.
Um,
and those images haunt me.
So,
um,
I got back to the hotel at the NGO was still working on their TV film that they
were doing and I put it into the laptop and scan it up.
And I looked at it and I just thought,
wow.
Yeah,
that is how I want to remember Liberia.
I don't want to remember it as this place that has been incarcerated.
Um,
I want to remember it for the beauty that it has within its,
you know,
the humor,
the beauty of the humanity there.
That's what I wanted to show because I don't want to come away from places and
shoot images of people at their expense.
I'm just,
that's not me.
I'm,
I think the human race is a majestic species.
And if I'm out there and I want to shoot this,
I want to show it cause it's there,
it's everywhere and you just have to see it.
You just see it and you go,
that's what a human should look like.
And,
and even in the worst,
the worst conditions imaginable,
it's there.
And that picture was it for me from Liberia.
And that's,
you know,
I have pictures from Liberia that I keep,
but that's the one that I'm really proud of because,
uh,
it was sharp.
Thank God.
Um,
but it just,
her beauty in that mess was what I wanted to remember.
And it just shows you that there,
you look for it.
It's,
it's everywhere.
You just have to,
you have to want to find it.
It's easy to just go in there and shoot what's obvious.
You know,
it's like sometimes you're going to situation like that.
It's like shooting fish in a barrel.
It's that point your camera at shoot,
but you just got to,
you know,
if you're looking for it,
you'll find it,
you know,
keep your eyes peeled.
Yeah.
And you from there
you ended up also going to South Sudan and again,
just just to a place of complete darkness
for those either,
don't know anything about Sudan.
Pulled a little clip
from the independent.
A guy named,
this is 2014.
See Oban Fenton wrote this,
more than a hundred children had been killed in South Sudan,
whilst many others have been raped and castrated.
According to UNICEF,
UNICEF says at 129 children had been burned in the last three weeks alone while
surviving.
Boys were castrated in girls were raped.
They say that some children were even thrown into burning buildings.
The executive director of UNICEF,
Anthony Lake,
said the violence against children in South Sudan has reached a new level of
brutality.
The details of the worsening violence against children are unspeakable,
but we must speak of them.
Survivors report that boys had been castrated and left to bleed to death.
Girls as young as eight had been gang raped and murdered children had been tied
together before their attackers slit their throats.
Others have been thrown into burning buildings.
Just a nightmare scenario.
Yup.
Any in you and want to clarify one thing.
You're working for an NGO.
For those of you who don't know what that is,
it's a non government organization.
Generally you're talking about some kind of a benevolent organization that is
trying to do good in the world such as the Red Cross is up is probably the
premier example.
Yeah.
I know you weren't specifically working for the Red Cross,
but you were working for another benevolent organization when they called you up
and brought you down to
South Sudan.
And again,
you're not,
for the most part,
going to the front lines and capturing the action of the war.
What you're capturing is the results of the war.
Sure.
In what did you see when you got to,
when you got to sit down?
Um,
well we flew into Juba.
and what,
what we were looking at where the UN camps,
so the situation in South Sudan was that the two tribes,
the Dinka tribe,
and they knew her tribe where I'm at war with each other and there was a lot of
fighting and killing going on and what the UN was trying to do,
um,
was segregate the tribes from each other in certain areas so that they just stop
killing each other.
Um,
because until the killing stopped then really that politically they were never
going to come to a,
um,
and,
and you had the president and the vice president were,
one was a Dinka and one was in Newark and whatever was happening between them
was being married,
you know,
on the street,
so to speak.
So,
and there was never any trust between those two men.
They have a lot of history and there was never too much trust.
So,
uh,
it was,
you know,
when they got their independence,
I think sit down,
it was only three years had been independent for three years.
I sit down.
Yeah.
So,
um,
we were visiting,
uh,
camps that were,
you know,
had segregated the tribes and Juba was probably the most,
uh,
aggressive camp in that,
the only time we ever had any trouble was,
uh,
maybe if some,
a couple of guys had got ahold of some alcohol and they wanted to know,
hey,
what are you doing here?
You know,
in this place,
why are you here?
Why are you taking,
and what you have to remember is these people don't want to be photographed in
this situation.
This is not a good situation for them.
And it's very easy as it,
as it,
as a journalist is going into a situation.
So yes,
I have to document this and I have to show what's going on.
But you have to understand that the dignity of these people needs to be taken
into consideration.
And you know,
some people are fine,
they're fine to let you photograph and they go,
yeah,
well this is where I am at the moment.
And so yeah,
I'm quite happy for you to,
to photograph me in.
And others quite playing the [inaudible].
So,
um,
apart from the,
uh,
the sort of criteria that the,
the,
the NGO was looking for and the NGO was effectively providing water
for these camps because,
uh,
and they would,
they'd worked out some sort of desalination process and they were able to
produce water on a regular basis,
uh,
for the camps.
But the situation in the camps was incredible.
They were just so overcrowded.
And again,
you know,
back to that sort of scenario of people being cramped on top of each other and
then,
you know,
that's how diseases spread and you know,
so on.
So,
um,
uh,
we,
then I,
there were obviously certain parts of South Sudan that I wanted to travel to
because I knew that the situation up in those parts of the country was,
it was even worse than,
uh,
you know,
Juba was relatively stable compared to other parts of Sudan.
There was a,
there was a place called Ben to you that I wanted to get to and there's a lot of
oil up there and both trying to try and they can try to control the,
or that's what they need to get hold of.
And,
um,
and as we were sort of,
I'd say,
listen,
let's go there.
And the NGO security,
we say,
you can't because there's fighting and we don't,
we're not allowing staff to fly in.
And the only,
the only time aid is getting to these places is there is helicopter drops,
but no one's touching the ground.
And,
you know,
the Ngo,
um,
are very hot on security.
Uh,
I mean it's Oxfam.
The NGO was Oxfam and they're incredibly professional organization and they're
very hot on security.
Um,
and anywhere you go,
if you go to any country working for Oxfam,
the first thing you get is a security briefing.
And they tell you what the situation is,
what you can and can't do,
where they advise that we don't go.
And these are the regulations and the stipulations that they make and you have
to adhere to them because you're there as a member of staff with,
even though I'm a freelancer and I can technically do what I like,
you have to really sort of bear in mind that you are out there working with
Oxfam staff and Oxfam staff.
I've traveled out from the UK with you.
So you really can't just go off and start doing what you like because you could
put other people's lives in jeopardy.
So everywhere,
um,
we want it to go,
I particularly wanted to go,
we couldn't,
and it was just always the case.
I wanted to go here.
No,
you can't go there,
but you can go here.
So we ended up traveling to areas that weren't where they,
the risk,
the security risk was pretty low.
Um,
and these were camps,
UN camps,
a UN mission camps that,
um,
uh,
we're created to where the fighting was at his worst and they were trying to
stop the tribes and killing each other.
Um,
and one of the places we went to,
which I will never forget as a place called ball and,
uh,
we sort of flew in,
um,
in a small plane and we got,
uh,
I think it was a helicopter then a small plane.
And fortunately we didn't have to drive,
um,
because I've been on a few journeys through Africa,
you know,
maybe 10,
14 hours in a car where there's no road.
Um,
so we were grateful to be able to fly in and you couldn't always flying.
We'd always get in that maybe a UN helicopter that was dropping something and we
just get in there and,
and fly it with them.
And we got to this place and Oxfam were working there and they were providing
water and they had this situation where w where the camp was,
the camp was being run by the current,
the South Koreans and they were sort of the,
they were physically building the camp and they were in charge of it at the
time.
Um,
and they had created this space,
maybe the size of two British football pictures or maybe a couple of American
football pitchers,
similar sort of thing,
uh,
for the,
for,
for people to live on.
And in this you had south Sudanese,
uh,
they were the,
um,
new or tribe living in here.
And uh,
you had,
you had wealthy,
um,
you had middle class and you had very poor living alongside each other in the
camp.
So there was a real mix of people in the camp and Oxfam work providing water.
And uh,
there was a huge reservoir,
but it wasn't a reservoir.
It was just a huge pit of water that had gone stagnant.
And every time it rained it would flood and flood into the camp.
So they were having to control that.
And keep making sure that that never got flooded.
And at the same time they were producing water with this filtration system and
providing pumps that people could,
you know,
and then basically sent them,
listen,
if you want to come to the pump and take water,
you got to learn how to clean your bucket so they wouldn't,
so they would in installing discipline into them.
Uh,
so,
you know,
and we support that.
Absolutely.
And,
um,
so,
but it wasn't as simple as US turning up with,
I was able to filmmaker a journalist and myself,
the three of us,
and it wasn't as simple as just marching into the camp and saying,
hey,
we're oxfam and we're here to take some pictures and shoot some film even though
Oxfam working there in that capacity.
So we had to go through the route of talking to the elder.
And the elder was a doctor who worked in Canada who'd come all the way back from
Canada.
And he described his journey to me of how he got to ball in South Sudan from
And I thought it was bad enough,
me coming from London Heathrow to get to South Sudan.
It was just,
I think it took him 11 days of pure travel to get from yeah,
it was,
it was unbelievable.
And planning about that traffic on the forums.
Yeah,
totally.
It was,
it was just,
it was humbling and he was there to rescue his mother and get her say,
and uh,
this was a camp,
so we had to talk to him and he wanted to know a little bit about us and he
said,
you're fine.
You can come in when we don't let any journalists in here,
the journalists just come here and they do their story and they leave at our
expense.
We don't have that,
but you,
you're providing water,
you guys can come in.
And so we had carte blanche to wander through the camp and do it well.
And everybody knew the elder has granted these,
these guys are cool.
They're fine duty.
Like,
so,
um,
this was a camp that had been attacked by the Dinka tribe a month earlier.
And in order to try and build you a picture,
if you can imagine the two football pictures.
Um,
you had the,
you had the UN camp and then within the UN camp there was this other camp that
they were living in and it had a perimeter around it.
It was just barbed wire and a perimeter and it was about the size of two
football pitches.
And they were wanting,
the Koreans were meant to be building another space because their latrines had
collapsed because of the rain.
And they,
you know,
it was just,
it was,
the conditions were,
uh,
were abominable.
But this perimeter was on the outside of the perimeter was dinker land and the
dinkiest had come in and they had attacked one night.
They had just stood on the,
on the outside,
over the fence and with machine guns just shot away.
And they killed a hundred of the tribe.
Women,
children,
kids.
I mean,
we were talking to kids were bullets were coming through.
they just live in it.
It's literally a couple of bamboo poles and some just white material.
That's what these people were living in.
But if you went into these homes that they've created,
they were just spotless inside.
And then you realize,
again,
the dignity that,
you know,
you have to be,
you just have to be so careful as you just don't wander around Gungho.
Just,
you know,
these,
there are very,
very,
these are very proud people and they're in this situation they want to be.
And what's more,
they can't get out because if they try and leave this camp,
they'll just,
they'll just be shot dead,
you know,
um,
by the opposing tribe.
And it was like that throughout Sudan.
So it didn't,
it wasn't necessarily just one try being protected.
It was the dinker in one campy.
It was newer than the other and there've been protection.
I was.
And um,
they were,
I remember you saying old age Ahca.
Did you ever notice the,
the state of their lives or their fear ever being etched on their faces,
wherever you've traveled.
And if this was one place that I saw it,
it was in this camp,
um,
and they were petrified that this was going to happen again.
Um,
because the,
the UN hadn't reacted in time when the first attack happened.
Um,
and so they just thought this is just going to happen again and who's going to
protect us.
And uh,
that is a,
again,
a situation where you're thinking when I leave this I'm getting on my plane and
I'm going to fly home.
And yet they are still going to be in that camp and they are still not going to
be able to leave.
And in this camp you will talking to young guys that were professionals working
in Juba and you know,
you're,
it's,
yeah.
That was the closest I had as an experience to Sri Lanka was South Sudan.
And you brought that attitude hole and your next as usual.
Yeah.
Your next assignment that you shot,
oddly enough was something that you had scheduled the six months prior.
You said,
you know what,
I'm going to go and just take a breather.
I'm going to go and shoot Wimbleton the tennis tournament in England on the
grass courts.
You'd schedule that in the meantime you,
you go to Sudan,
you experienced this when you get home.
And this was just on your own,
you just schedule it for yourself to choose you when we'll show.
Yeah.
Noncommissioned and you brought this back with you and what did that do to your,
your Wimbleton shoot?
Uh,
well originally I,
um,
I think it was a couple of weeks before Wimbledon started and,
I was not in the slightest bit interested in going to shoot the story and I'd
gone to all this trouble to get this accreditation.
And the,
the,
the photographer that runs,
uh,
the Wimbledon is also a very,
very,
how to respect to sports photographer who also runs the photography of the
Olympics.
And he'd said,
Karen,
listen,
um,
I'd be happy to come in and shoot whatever it is you want to shoot.
Uh,
and I'd gone to all that trouble to get that and he'd given it his blessing and
I thought,
you know what,
I'm just going to turn.
And I said to Bob died that really fancy this,
cause I've just been in South Sudan living in with,
with these people in these camps.
And the idea of going to England,
shooting people,
eating,
drinking champagne and eating strawberries and cream it really fast.
I'm just that,
that's what echo and I like to call a rough transients.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and on top of that,
it was a self commission.
So in as a freelancer,
self commissioning and not only any money,
it's not really the greatest idea in the world,
but,
um,
but over time,
as we got closer,
I just thought,
hey,
do you know what,
hey white.
Yeah,
okay.
Maybe I'll,
I'll go and do this.
So I went for the first couple of days and,
uh,
I just,
I'd had an idea,
I wanted to see if Wimbledon still had any charm,
because I went with my dad when I was 10 years old and I never forgot it.
I got to see John Mcenroe and Peter,
Peter Fleming.
Uh,
yeah.
Peter Fleming,
not Ian Fleming,
p play doubles.
Um,
I bumped into John Lloyd,
a British tennis player at the time.
Uh,
just,
and I just remember thinking that was a magical afternoon I had with my dad for
my birthday when I was 10 years old.
Um,
let's see if Wimbledon still has that magic at bearing in mind that I had shot
15 Wimbledon's previously in my career as a professional sitting on court
shooting the tennis.
You know,
I was there when Venus,
when I first,
I was there when Roger Federer beat Sampras,
you know,
seminal moments in sport.
So I just wanted to see if at any time,
no,
that was my original intention when I got the press quotation six myzone that
completely went out the window.
I wasn't interested in one of them that in each arm or not.
Uh,
I just thought,
I'm going to go up and I'm going to photograph those people that can't,
that just get,
can get the cheapest ticket and get in and just wander around the outside
courts.
I don't want to see a tennis player.
I don't want to go anywhere near the show courts.
I just want to see what it's like to be a punter.
Because when I came up,
when I was 10 years old,
that's all I was with my dad.
We were just two punches that managed to sneak two tickets to get into show
court to see Mcenroe and Fleming play doubles.
So,
uh,
in a way I was,
I may be trying to see if you did have a bit charm.
I think so,
but I that had really gone out of my head.
So I,
I turned up and I just started walking around and,
uh,
the,
my attitude was,
well,
do you know what I,
it doesn't matter if I don't get a picture and because who's going to shout at
me?
Who's going to say,
Kieran,
what have you got today?
No one,
only me.
So I just might,
my mindset changed dramatically and I just started wandering around and I
remember I used to hang around in the attic,
cause a precipice.
I just go into the,
uh,
media,
haul with where my,
all my mates were working,
you know,
slugging their guts out,
covering the tennis because it sounds really glamorous.
Uh,
but it's,
it's full on shooting tennis at Wimbledon.
It really is full on.
And um,
they just,
you say a kid hanging around in the CAF a lot.
I was like,
yeah,
I know because I'm just waiting for the lights and just go out and see what
there is,
you know?
Um,
and then,
Oh God,
I've got to go and sit on center court for another four hours and then Andy
Murray is going to come on a play in,
the roof's going to come over and aren't going to get out of here till 10
o'clock.
And I really,
yeah,
I'll be gone by six,
you know,
cause the light will have gone then and there'll be no need for me to be here.
And then I'd have another cup of coffee and wander out and just wander around.
And I just had one camera and one Lens,
just a small liker and a 35 mil.
And um,
I'd wander and wander and wander.
And first couple of days I didn't get anything I thought,
hmm,
okay.
So I decided,
okay,
let's go on day three.
And I went on day three and I remember walking around and what had happened at
this Wimbledon is that occasionally they build a new court and when they build a
new court it means the dynamics of that area since last year have changed.
So,
um,
walls have gone up and,
and in a Wimbledon,
they're not walls,
they put sort of green sheeting,
very thick,
heavy sheeting across to sort of delineate this is a new court.
Well what that means is that the security guards who are employed,
who are just young guys looking for so much gel,
you know,
they're employed,
they haven't got a clue what the dynamics are of this court because this is
caught only existed this year.
And all these new things have been put in place.
And so I remember just coming around the corner and I saw this guy standing with
his face right up to the Green Bay's like this.
And I thought it's as if he'd been sent to the naughty step is,
you know,
face the wall son.
I thought,
what is going on here?
So I was sort of watching and I took a few pictures and I thought,
okay,
and he's getting a little bit closer here.
And as I did that,
somebody else walked past me and just went straight up to the wall and put there
like this.
I thought,
God,
there must be a pinpricks in the material that allows them to put their eye
right up to it and they can see the whole court.
And you know,
I thought that that's what they're doing.
Okay,
right.
I get it now.
So I thought,
well all I need is for 10 people to just do this.
And Oh,
I've got a picture.
So as I'm doing this,
as I'm waiting for this moment to evolve,
I'm thinking,
I haven't got a picture yet at Wimbledon and this could be my first.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to let this one mature and see what happens.
And as I did that,
this guy turns up,
young guy turns up with a pram and he takes his kid out of the Pram and his kid
has this shock of red hair and he's maybe eight months old.
No,
maybe a year old.
A bit older than that.
Yeah.
But a year old,
still a really tiny baby and his wife walks past and his wife goes to join the
three other people that are peering through like this.
And I thought,
okay,
right,
I've got us and there's four people there and like this.
And then I don't know what this guy's doing with this baby.
I mean,
what,
you know,
this baby's got such an amazing shock of red hair.
It looked fantastic against the green.
So I've got to this,
what's going to happen?
And this guy just pick the baby up and shoved the baby's head over the top of
the base.
And before I took a picture,
I thought,
why are you doing that?
Because the baby can't see anything.
And you certainly,
and I think in his mind he thought if I shoved the baby's head over the top,
I'll be able to see something as if it was like a periscope,
which is what I mean.
And it was so bizarre and he kept it there and I thought,
all right,
time to take a picture.
So I took this picture and as I took the picture,
there was an old boy standing behind me selling programs and he went,
hmm,
that's a hell of a picture you've got there.
And I thought,
yeah,
it is and let's,
I'm just going to see if something else happens with the baby.
You know,
I don't know what's going on,
but it didn't.
And I had my picture.
But what I really wanted was to have been on the other side of that court and
just seeing that baby's head appear over the top.
So that was my first picture and I thought,
okay,
this has,
and that's how I normally work.
Get one under your belt and build on it.
And I thought that's a very funny picture.
That is how I'm going to look at this story.
I'm going to find the humorous elements of being upon Sir in Wimbledon and I
want to shoot it as if you were.
So when you look at the pictures,
you think,
why has he shot that picture with those two heads in the way?
And I can only just see that tennis player and I might,
my point is the,
well,
if you're a punter at Wimbledon Das,
exactly how you see it.
You don't the cheap seats.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
and,
and most of these seats,
or you just walk around and stand.
So you're always crouching and trying to see.
And I just thought,
and of course,
I,
I very rarely look through the camera.
I'd see a situation and just go,
there you go.
Because I didn't care.
I actually didn't care whether I got anything that was any good.
Uh,
I just thought,
you know,
this is a nice feeling to just wander around and just click away.
Um,
and I wasn't framing anything.
I was framing,
but framing in a way for a purpose,
but I didn't care.
And it,
and if somebody said to me,
is that the result of two weeks at Wimbledon,
I would have said,
yeah,
you know,
I don't care.
And I,
I,
I really,
really don't care.
So that was,
that was the attitude with which,
um,
I shot it.
And,
um,
yeah.
So to finish this story,
so come,
that was June,
and come January,
2015 are the big in the world of photojournalism,
the world press photo through awards and I the world.
And those are like the uh,
the Oscars yeah.
Of A for photojournalism.
Yeah,
they're the big ones.
And um,
and I remember when I was a young kid,
I always used to print my stuff up,
you know,
when I was starting in,
send it in and then look at the stuff and go,
why didn't I win anything?
Well that's because,
you know,
my stuff was just crap.
Uh,
and that's why I didn't win anything.
So I sort of stopped entering competitions when I resigned from Reuters in 2008.
It just didn't really interest me anymore.
But a friend of mine rang me up and he said,
you have entered those woman pictures into wordpress road.
And I said,
no.
And he said,
okay,
and you've got to,
you've got to do their amazing pictures of you.
And I thought,
well,
you're the only one that thinks that they're amazing pictures.
I was happy with them,
but you know,
and he said,
no,
do it.
So I did and I had to submit 10 pictures and I found 14 images that were
potential and I got down to seven and I then I called [inaudible] and I said to
tear,
listen,
you've got to find another three pictures out of this,
these five or six,
which three do you think she'd go into the sentence
and Tsa,
that one,
that one and that one is it great.
That was it.
And then it went
and lo and behold it won.
Southern won an Oscar.
So yeah.
Uh,
and,
and the irony of the story was a self commissioned yourself and earn no money
and you win a big award.
I want to cover one more thing before we wrap this up and one more series of,
of images that you took and I'll start this off with a poem.
The poem is called repatriation.
Then I'm just going to do an excerpt from it.
The coffin draped in union.
Jack is slowly carried out the back out of the dark and into the light,
slowly down the ramp.
And to the right,
the six approach,
the hearse all black and place the hero gently in the back.
The sixth then turn and March away.
Their duty has been done this day.
Politicians usually have much to say,
no sign of them near here this day they hide away and out of danger much easier.
If the hero is a stranger.
The hearse with its precious load move slowly out onto the road.
The floral tributes line the route.
While comrade snap a smart salute
at the edge of wheelchair town.
The court judge slows it's pace right down.
The streets are packed.
Many deep,
some throw flowers.
Most just weep.
The crowd have come to say farewell.
The church bell rings a low death knell.
Regimental standards are lower down.
As the hero passed through the town,
the court did stops and silence rains.
The town's folk feel the family's pain.
The nation's flag lowered to half mast.
Our brave hero is home at last.
That was written by Sergeant Andrew Macfarlane in 2009 about a place in England
called Wootton Bassett,
which is where all British soldiers and service members that were killed in
action or brought back home to England.
And you shot some
amazing photographs of that.
And this is
when I,
when I first got to know you,
this was the first thing I found out was that you'd shot these photos and
okay,
they're,
they're just incredible and they represent
really to me just a
and incredible a view of England and what England is in the world.
And how did you
end up there once again with your camera in your hand?
I was assigned the first,
the first time I ever went to it and pass it,
it was on an assignment and I turned up and I was told at the only,
the only information I was given was bring a really tall ladder,
um,
because you'll need it.
And I didn't understand the dynamics and of,
of what was happening on the streets.
So it was my first time and I,
I,
you know,
I got there and the traffic was awful in the,
and I literally arrived maybe 20 minutes before the Cortez came through.
So I was running down the street with my [inaudible] okay,
here with the other photographers,
this is what we do.
Put a ladder up here and,
and the latter became clear because you need to go to the top of the ladder.
So when the hearse has come down the street and stop and the family members put
their roses on the hearse,
you need to be able to see over the top of the hearse to be able to see the
grieving widows and relatives.
Um,
and you know,
you're standing on top of a six step ladder,
you know,
you're probably about 15 or 16 feet in the air and you'll really quite
conspicuous with a long lens.
Um,
and it wasn't something that I was really comfortable doing it because the click
of a camera in that silence was deafening.
Um,
and it was one of those things that wouldn't,
the,
the repatriations had been happening before for a while.
I think before I got there,
um,
and I mean years,
I may be 2008,
2007,
but before I,
you know,
I had actually turned up to um,
to shoot my first one.
So there had been a pattern that had developed over time and the pattern was
photography.
Sign up,
they sign up a ladder,
they shoot the pictures,
uh,
the event finishes it and everybody goes home and the pictures are wired.
And my first time I was there,
I ended up,
the best image I shot was from the floor of a younger holding red roses.
Wait,
looking down the street,
waiting for the,
the courthouse to pass.
And I was really aware of the ladders and the noise of the cameras and I
thought,
I can't,
I stopped myself from shooting because it was so loud and I thought,
I can't be the one.
And you would see something happening.
And you would see a moment when maybe a wife came out and she touched the back
of the hearse with our hand,
you know,
and put her head against the glass and you,
your instinct instinct is to shoot that.
And shoot as many frames as that as possible.
But I had my camera on single shots,
so I was click,
Click,
oh,
you could hear it was like machine guns of cameras.
And it was,
and it was so invasive.
And I thought,
well this is,
this is how the photographers got their pictures.
This is what they had to do.
There was no way around it.
And I decided that's fine,
I understand that.
That's what,
that's what we have to do to get the pictures,
but I'm not going to do that anymore.
I don't,
I really don't want to get involved in this anymore.
I found it too stressful.
And what I ended up doing was not shooting when I should have shot stopping
myself because I didn't want my click to be the click that everybody had.
And even though everybody had accepted that this is what happens,
I thought,
well,
I'm just not comfortable with this.
So I decided then that this was an amazing event and that I needed to look at
this properly.
And bearing in mind that I had been late for relatively,
um,
I hadn't seen what had happened before.
The hearse came.
I had no idea what,
what happened.
So the next time I went down,
I got down there really early and I there was known on the streets and I watched
the buildup and for those of that,
don't know
what the whole story but wouldn't bass it was,
it the bodies of,
um,
service personnel killed in action in Afghanistan,
uh,
were being repatriated to an air base and the only route out of the air base,
it was through this tiny village market town called the wooden back cold within
basad.
Uh,
as the,
uh,
the bodies were taken to the coroner's office in Oxford.
And it was the first time this happened,
the,
the horses came through and I think the town mayor spotted it and he just
stopped and doffed his cap as they went past.
And then that just exponentially grew into,
you'd have thousands on the street over the years.
It just grew into thousands and,
and then the families change their routine.
The families would just go to the base in Lineman and pay their final respects.
Uh,
and then they would leave.
But what happened was that the families would then pay their final respects and
then everybody would wait for the families to come to the street and stand on
the street.
And so that you could see how the whole thing was evolving into this sort of
incredible 10 minutes.
And it started with,
people would turn up on the street and you'd find people that hadn't seen each
other for years and they were just,
um,
hey,
how's it going?
Do you fancy going to the pub for a pint?
And they'd go and they'd have a drink and there would be this,
it was almost like a party atmosphere.
People were already pleased to see each other and there was this lively,
bubbly noise going on and people were laughing and joking.
Then the families would turn up and everything would sort of calmed down just a
little bit.
And then the bells would toll in the church.
And there was complete silence.
And then the Cortez would come through and it would stop and it would be led by
a lead sort of pull bear and it would stop and it would give five minutes with
the families.
And then sometimes it was just one horse.
Sometimes it was,
I did one occasion,
there was six,
six verses.
It came in.
Um,
and,
and then it would leave and then everybody would disperse and then it would
happen again.
And then again.
And it would,
could be two,
could be twice a week,
it might be once a month.
But I'd said every time it happens,
I'm going to go down and shoot the story in a linear fashion because I just
wanted to show everything from start to finish.
So when you look at the essay of 50 pictures,
it starts at the beginning with the street empty and then it works up to the
last thing you see on the street.
And the roses as the horses have driven off and the rest of the form of the
hoses.
Um,
but I couldn't do it as a press photographer would do it.
I had to find a way of doing it and because I would just want it to get those
moments.
I was looking for something completely different to what may be the newspapers
and the wire agencies were looking for.
So I decided to shoot on film and I have to Leica m six is and I had a 28 mil
and the 50 mil and I put film in a,
because I could operate and you just can't hear those cameras.
That's just uh,
um,
as opposed to the digital,
which was really loud.
Um,
and I started shooting it on film and it was really hit and miss.
I'd get stuff and I go down there on some occasions and I'd get nothing,
but every time I went down as I was building the story,
I knew,
okay,
I'll look at the situation and work out what I'm going to get from this today
and concentrate on one thing.
And invariably you would construe it in one thing,
but what you would get was something that would happen somewhere else.
Um,
and so it meant getting into positions that the press we're not supposed to be
getting into.
So I would want to go onto the other side of the street,
which was reserved for family.
I mean anyone could stand them,
but the unwritten rule was this is for family and I didn't want to intrude on
the family and their grief and I wasn't there to photograph their grief from my
position up close.
I just wanted to see the reaction of people around there that I couldn't see
from the other side of the road.
So I was taking pictures and I felt so conspicuous and I was there with these
two tiny cameras,
but I felt so conspicuous,
but no one was looking at me and I was able to just turn the camera around and
just prefocused and shooting.
I don't put it to my,
I just turn around,
click shoot.
Um,
so everything was sort of one,
one frame.
Um,
and yeah,
I sort of gradually sort of built the story up and I knew that it had an ending
because it,
the Ebay they were coming into originally before it came to wooden Bassett had
been rebuilt and all the bodies were going to be repatriated back to the other
air base.
So I knew at some point,
uh,
in August,
2011,
there would be the last repatriation.
So,
um,
the,
the fights you have with yourself when you're looking at the story and you're
sitting there thinking,
okay,
I think I need these,
I need an image here to fill this gap.
Is that your waiting for a soldier to die in order for you to finish your story?
And it's not that you're waiting for a soldier to die,
but a soldier dies and you or you know,
in order for you to finish it yet,
this isn't that I'm not even articulate enough to explain what I mean by that.
But the idea that you hear on the news,
two soldiers had been killed.
Um,
and you think,
okay,
that's me going back down to wouldn't pass it to finish this story.
So the idea that I had a purpose of going down to a place like that was really
hard to deal with because people,
w everyone else down there was there because they were involved in or directly
involved with the soldier or they were people that just went to pay their
respects.
And so you could say,
in a way,
if I wanted to justify it to myself,
you are paying your respects in a way because I wanted to,
I wanted this story to be shot from start to finish because I think it deserved
that.
It wasn't just about grieving family members on the other side of a hearse,
you know,
weeping.
It,
there was so much more to that story than that.
And so gradually the story began to sort of fill itself out.
And,
um,
and then in the end,
the,
uh,
I was there for the final repatriation and,
um,
the town was then awarded royal status,
which is the first time that happened,
I don't know,
I think over a hundred years because it was the way I think that they,
they were the town,
the way that it conducted itself,
um,
was recognized
by the royal family and they just sort of said,
listen,
the,
what you've done,
you've,
you've not just put work and pass it on the map,
but you've shown how much dignity the British show when you know that those that
are fighting for their country or coming back and,
and the way,
the whole thing and,
and wouldn't pass it.
They didn't want the adulation.
They didn't want to be known as this place.
They just thought the,
we need to do this.
Um,
and yep,
it's from the heart.
Like we were saying earlier,
there's no,
there was no ulterior motive from that town to do what they did.
It just happened.
It was organic and I wanted to show that story.
Um,
and so,
yeah,
that was it,
that it took,
I think it was 19 months of going down and I'm
photographing it in every,
you know,
from,
from every conceivable angle.
And I was really proud of the finished set of pictures.
I thought that tells the story,
um,
from how I saw it from start to finish.
Um,
and yeah,
it was,
um,
and when it,
when it,
when it finished,
I didn't know how I felt because I thought,
you know,
when you get so used to doing something and you know,
I don't want soldiers to die so that I can go down and finish the story,
but he try and work out how to,
how do I,
how do I mentally get my head around what's happening here,
you know?
But the,
the thing that's come out of it is that,
um,
on the final
repatriation,
I wanted the pictures to be exhibited down that I wanted to show wouldn't acid
while I spent 18 months doing,
but I didn't want to stick prince in a room and I didn't want,
you know,
I just thought these pictures,
I,
this is,
I shot this on the streets.
These pictures need to be on the street.
So I went down and I found a bank that said to me,
you can have both double fronted windows of our bank and you can put your images
up during the final repatriation because they thought we would love people to
see this imagery.
And the reaction it got,
I was really quite nervous because there were 50 images going up,
printed on a one size in a bank's shot,
went in,
in,
in the glass and the window.
Uh,
and I was really quite nervous as to how people would look at it.
I thought would,
you know,
would,
would people appreciate this?
And they loved it.
They loved the fact that this had been done.
And when I went back down to collect the images,
um,
I would say half of them,
I just gave away to the pub where you have the pictures of the soldiers saluting
outside the pub that everybody went to.
There was the old lady standing in the glass window.
There was the kid wearing the Chelsea shirt.
All these pictures just went.
And I just said,
listen,
just put some money in the charity box and just take the prints.
Because if all of them had gone,
I would have thought that was fantastic because I didn't want to keep them.
I just wondered if somebody,
I thought,
if somebody wants that and they want it,
that's amazing.
And a lot of them went.
Um,
and that to me was indication of having spent that time and done it,
you know?
Um,
and during that time,
as a photographer,
I grew because I sort of come out of that
way of shooting for the y,
which is all about a single image.
Tell a story in the single image,
in a,
an eye,
I suppose ever from ever since the beginning,
I've always been a photography,
wanted to tell a story,
but with a series of images,
not just,
and there's a skill to doing what the why guys do.
And,
and,
and I had that skill and I did it,
but I wanted to just expand my palate as a photographer.
And that meant
spending time on stories and trying to tell it as you know,
as a complete,
so you could take one picture out of there and go,
well,
what does that mean?
That picture?
But if you put it into the set,
you go,
oh,
okay,
now I know what it means.
So you'll not shooting standalone images that you're shooting images.
That means something when they're put together as a,
as a package.
Um,
yeah.
And that was,
yeah,
I was very proud of those pictures.
Well,
like I said,
those pictures are,
are amazing.
And,
and I think they did exactly what,
why Wootton Bassett was,
what was it named?
A royal town boy wouldn't mess it.
Royal wouldn't pass it.
I think it reflected exactly what that,
what that put forth in that as the,
the pride of England,
the honor of England,
the respect of England.
And I think that was all captured not only in the town but of the images that
you took.
And I think we've been going for a long time right now and
I think that's about all we've got for tonight.
I know,
I do want to say,
obviously,
thanks for coming on.
I know I worked with,
uh,
some photographers overseas.
Some of them just took incredible risks to get the capture,
to capture the moments that they captured,
you know,
uh,
the book of life.
And I wrote guide named Todd Pittman,
who is their combat.
He was,
he was a photographer and just took some incredible images.
And we,
we were honored to,
to be able to take those images and putting them in the book.
But I know there's
many,
obviously many photographers,
journalists around the world that take great risks to report and capture the
stories and get them spread around and,
and a lot of them were killed.
And you mentioned one at the beginning,
but a lot of,
there's a lot of reporters and photographers,
journalists that are out there in the world that they take huge risks and
sometimes they pay the ultimate price for their job.
This was a,
I know I've said a couple of things on the podcast that were pretty rough.
I appreciate everyone for sticking through those,
those tough moments.
Appreciate you traveling to those places and sticking through those tough
moments yourself,
Karen,
and thanks for everybody for,
for listening to the podcast.
If you do want to support the podcast
that go
tell him how to support it.
My brother,
well we didn't really talk much about working out or anything that would
constitute much supplementation,
but what about Alpha brain out for brain?
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
Cause you gotta be quick with your finger on the trigger of your,
of your camera.
In some cases you might want to get some of that Alpha brain I was talking to
was just,
I was talking to somebody,
this is like yesterday,
the day before about photography and
you know how people,
they'll see like a real good picture and they'll be like,
hey,
that's a good,
that's a cool picture.
What camera did you use?
Do you ever find that insulting?
Uh,
I've heard it.
I've heard it compared to like
this girl.
I know Holly,
she's active enough and a photographer and uh,
she said it like this once when someone asked her what kind of camera she is.
Like that's a great picture of what kind of camera did you use tsheets lake
saying,
hey,
that's a great meal.
What kind of stove did you use?
Something like that.
Yeah,
I know.
I get that meeting you at the archer.
It was the bow and the Arrow that made it a good shot.
Right,
exactly.
I think I've had it the other way around.
I've had people say,
wow,
that's a lovely looking camera.
You must have shot some great pictures with that,
you know,
so yeah,
that's probably enlite but in reverse know.
Um,
but uh,
but you keep it traditional too.
I mean,
I mean obviously you're doing manual focus on film a lot of times digital.
This is,
this is the,
yeah.
Manual manual focus on digital as well.
Yeah.
But I've been using them so for 20 odd years.
So not the like is they're not everybody's cup of tea.
I know a lot of professional photographers,
they're not,
you know,
it's not their cup of tea,
but,
and,
and also,
you know,
it's a particular type of,
for the journalists I think that uses a camera like this.
And when I say particular,
I mean they shoot particular stories and a particular way.
It's not that you know,
they're any better than anybody else.
They certainly aren't.
They just choose to use a camera that doesn't have long lenses.
And I like to use a cabinet,
doesn't,
my longest lens is a 50 mil.
You got to stock your target.
Yeah.
I like to use these are quiet and you're getting close.
Even that,
that's
so much detailed to the art,
you know,
we're of course equipment is something sure.
Like distinct part of it.
And I think it's,
I think photography gets it the most,
I think because it's like,
like I said,
I want the photographer now.
Absolutely.
There we good.
I can take a picture.
You mean a good camera Mike and look like that and everybody can,
everybody has it in them to shoot a beautiful picture.
I firmly believe everybody can shoot a great picture.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
But yeah,
so I'll put rain,
boom picks him alpha.
Take better pictures of tension of the day.
There you go.
Fuck.
Gotta Lug heavy camera equipment around.
You know there's some shooting tech for tech for that one.
Yeah.
Running TV as sewage.
That could have helped you in the later.
Yeah,
that's right.
Um,
and I've just discovered these tonight as well.
Or are your bars solid?
Right?
Yeah.
I'm not a good host.
Didn't feed him.
My wife,
my wife said,
what is wrong with you?
Why don't you Pete give him some food?
And I said,
okay,
he needs food for your bar.
And she was like,
Dems,
mine,
boom,
worry bar.
So yeah,
if you,
uh,
if you want to get 10% off those jock on att.com/jocko boom,
10% off.
So supplement yourself,
Supplement your,
your what your wallet if you will.
There you go.
Or if you want to support before you shop on Amazon,
good at our websites,
one of them Jocko store or Jocko podcast.com.
Click through the Amazon link.
Support passively.
Passively?
No.
Efficiently.
Efficiently,
yes.
Passively?
No,
we don't read things passive here at the Jocko podcast.
Aggressively make things efficient.
Guess so we do here.
Amazon.
All right,
well you want to get more efficient and also UK is working.
Yeah,
the UK is up solid German working Germany is,
we'll be,
we're all working candida.
We know it's working.
Yup.
So if you're in those countries,
appreciate the support Amazon,
click through trooper to troubel or less.
What I'm saying that if you want to get efficient,
ultra aggressively efficient,
I like it was supporting through Amazon.
Just go,
go to the website instead of the Amazon link.
Click on the trooper tool.
Jocko podcasts.
Trooper tool,
chrome extension,
boom.
Adds a little thing on your browser.
Automatically support every time you put a,
every time you,
you shop Amazon,
that's legit.
Very legit.
My opinion.
Thanks again Brady for that one.
Tech Genius Jujitsu student.
And if you wear tee shirts,
go to Jocko store.com.
You might like some of those,
uh,
you know,
discipline equals freedom.
Jack was head says good backwards.
The good is backwards.
So when you look in the mirror,
it's a message to you.
This is not for other people.
It's not for other people.
Just like this podcast is for you.
Everybody.
It's not for everybody.
This podcast is for you.
That's her
stickers.
But yeah,
stickers on there and travel mugs.
Cool bumper stickers.
But then I'm putting him on their bumpers.
No,
no,
they're putting them on their spot rack.
You know,
I go on my desk,
my whiteboard,
you know.
Awesome.
Yeah,
the stickers are bumper stickers with there for everything.
For sure.
Yeah.
So if you like that stuff,
um,
yeah man,
you can support that way.
That's a cool way.
Get one of those.
We'll send it to you.
Another thing.
We got little
bit of Jocko White Tea,
pomegranate style.
It should be coming out in the next few weeks just to keep checking back to the
website.
It comes in a cool 10 know and it says Jocko White Tea on it pomegranate.
Cause that's how I do things.
People like what we need to do is come up with a really cool name for the
podcast and I go,
okay Jocko podcast,
boom.
Well we need to come up with a cool name for the Jocko white tea.
Okay Jocko white tea.
Boom.
Cause we're not,
you know what,
just do it.
We're just trying to keep things simple.
One of the laws of combat.
So check that out.
It is pomegranate white tea.
It's obviously,
I talked about that on the first,
my introduction to the world was when Tim Ferriss said I mixed up some,
some pomegranate white tea and you know Tim,
he's a,
he's an affection auto of t did that could shadow yeah,
that that too.
Yeah.
He has a special um,
kettle where you press what kind of tea you're drinking and it's going to bring
it to the appropriate temperature for that type of tea.
Green tea,
white tea,
black tea.
It's,
it's going to do it right.
He's got that thing,
he's got like a little shelf.
He's into his tea,
but he never had the white pomegranate tea before.
So when I showed up and I said,
hey,
you want some of this?
And so I mixed it up for him and he's drinking it in,
in,
we were starting to podcast in,
you know,
like 20 minutes in,
12 minutes later he starts going,
yeah,
that went well,
kind of.
He was that,
he was all kinds of fire.
So then the next thing that happened was on Amazon.
I would see people would order extreme ownership and then it would be like,
oh,
people that brought extreme ownership also bought pomegranate white tea.
And then finally one of the t people said,
hey,
do you need to have your own tea?
And I said,
okay,
start.
I'll make my own tea,
but it's going to be good,
real good.
So I went through it,
but it took a while because I kept saying,
no,
nope.
Do this.
Nope.
A little bit more of that.
And finally we got to the t that not only tastes good,
but it gives you the delight,
Pomegranate d power.
So be looking for that.
Uh,
speaking of extreme ownership,
you can buy that book written by myself and my brother Leif Babin.
You can get on hardcover where you can make lots of notes and put little tabs in
there and highlight stuff.
You can buy it on digital.
I think you could make notes notes on digital too,
but it doesn't look as cool.
Kindle.
Yeah,
you can put notes in kindle.
The kindle APP.
I don't know what it did without,
well,
I didn't really read before that,
but I'm just saying that you can go do notes
all at your finger to the really good.
That's good.
And I'm glad you did that.
Me Personally,
I need to have physical,
you know?
No,
I got my pen's lined up,
highlighters lined up,
you know,
things with the physical,
I mean,
can I really do the podcasts from a kindle?
Is that going to no,
no.
We
would have to shut down the podcast.
Well,
you'd have to learn how to use a kindle first.
You would,
oh,
I'd have to free my mind a little bit.
Yeah.
Then also the extreme ownership muster,
which is a little conference we're having out here in San Diego,
California.
If you want to talk about all this stuff in depth with some real focus myself
Lafe running this thing out here in San Diego,
California leadership conference,
but that's one way of looking at it.
Another way of looking at is frontal assault on your brain,
so come and get some of that October 20th and 21st
checkout echelon front.com for some details on that and also if you want to
continue this conversation,
you know that we're all up upon the interwebs.
Echo is at echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink,
Twitter Facebooky Instagram.
Here it is also on those various mediums and he's saw spell it.
Spell it.
Okay.
It's at I,
m k.
I.
E R.
A.
N D.
Okay.
And it's the same on Instagram.
And I'm the hearing dot hardy.
I am Karen Thompson,
but it's not.
I am.
That's a common one though.
Like people,
it's not like,
it's like,
oh shoot.
You know,
like what?
Repeat that because that's a common one.
Like they'll put the,
or I'm or I'm like,
I dunno,
MMA at the Anderson.
So that's a common one.
That's so it's not that hard to remember is what I'm saying.
India,
Mike,
Kilo India.
Go on down the line.
Yup.
I'll put it in the link.
Romeo Alpha,
November and I'm new to Twitter,
so I really need some friends,
followers.
Oh,
sorry.
Follows.
But,
but actually you have,
you do Instagram.
I do Instagram.
I guess that one's a little more obvious for you since you take pictures with
that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to thing,
yeah,
yeah.
Which is awesome.
Yeah.
Maybe since you're a photographer and whatnot and uh,
so Karen wants,
again,
thanks for coming on with my pleasure.
Thanks for sharing these stories.
It was awesome to talk to you.
[inaudible] good to see you again.
And
of course to the troopers out there that'll listen to this podcast.
Thanks for joining us here.
Thanks for looking at the world.
And even if you're not taking pictures of the world,
at least take the time to appreciate it.
All of it.
The good and the bad,
the light and the dark.
And while you're out there in the world,
okay,
go ahead and make sure you get after it too.
So until next time,
this is Kiran,
an echo and Jocko
out.